we are indeed live with the speed chess
championship I am here with womans
Grandmaster Jennifer Shehadeh this is
our second match of the first round
we're hosting together and as we look at
all the faces of these top players Jen
tell everybody how excited you are today
to see how you've on take on Fabiano
Caruana well this is just the best match
I could possibly hope to call with you
Danny two of my absolute favorite
players of all time yeah and I think
that this match has about as much
anticipation as any of the matches in
the first round
holy fun obviously brings a lot of star
power to the table and though she's the
underdog here against Fabiano Caruana
I think we know we're in for a super
interesting match and I can't wait to
see what we have in store let's remind
everybody of the format real quick
before we jump in and get the game
started it's gonna be 90 minutes of 5:00
to blitz 60 minutes of 3:2 and then a
half an hour of bullet chess the great
equalizer that is bullet and of course
chess960 game sprinkled throughout we
had some really interesting chess960
games yesterday Jen hopefully we got
more of those coming up and then of
course the prizes obviously the prizes
for the first few rounds are broken up
amongst these 16 superstars but the big
prizes the big prize is just moving on
to the next round as everybody knows the
prices increased significantly with
every match - eventually you get to the
finals and who knows who we will see you
can see the updated bracket in front of
you right now obviously yesterday the
seven seed
Jana pom neo she took down Levon Aronian
in a super closely contested match it
was a thriller and not quite that not
quite as close as the so Geary match but
just about and Jen as we as we move over
to the the the view here where we can
see both players are set we are getting
set to start the 5-2 portion you and I
saying hi to the fans now and we have
about 30 seconds and we have liftoff
here alright it can't wait I'm just
hoping for really exciting match like
yesterday as Danny I so enjoyed that and
there's just gonna be some great chess
today and that's all we can ask for
absolutely we have got both players
followed and
ready ready to rock at least I believe
that all players are online and and of
course they are because because the game
has just started here we go here we go
we're starting with double king pot and
I predict array Lopez there it is and
typical these days anti Berlin yeah how
much Theory you think we're gonna see
between these two players I always
wonder that sometimes the style of these
players and blitz and bullet is to mix
it up and poke and prod with something
obscure we solve Ivana Rhoni and play a
lot of veresov yesterday probably not
something he's gonna play so much in
classical chess but but then eventually
they transition to do it and do a lot of
theory in the Lopez and in the English
but between these two players what do
you think we're gonna see I think we're
gonna start with some more theory and
then as the time controls get faster
they're gonna switch it up and play more
random stuff okay well right now it
looks like we're on track to see exactly
that as we as we move over here and take
a peek into the players and and check
out our our analysis board we've got
hope on playing from Beijing today
everybody so it is it is exactly 6 a.m.
601 a.m. there so she had to get up
bright and early and and but Fabiano
playing on the East Coast along with ugn
and we will probably be seeing the dark
clouds as this match rolls on and it
becomes nighttime therefore both of you
in New York so it's the Battle of the
night Allen the morning lark indeed yeah
we'll see use more fatigue so what do we
got going on here in the position I wear
it's just all about who understands
things better than me it certainly seems
a bit more fun to play for white because
the Bishop 23 is so much stronger than
the bishop on any six
so starting out I gotta say I like
Fabiano's position okay but not a lot of
long-term weaknesses here for black
obviously you font just played the move
f6 and certainly we look at the light
squares as potentially weak but white
doesn't have a light square bishop so
how strong do you think an attack on the
kingside could actually be a Fabiano
gets a move like f5 and and maybe starts
attacking well really what I want is a
knight
five if I could get an F five my life
would be beautiful but I guess the
problem is like if we start moving our
night away from c3 the d5 is really what
hope you find we'll want to play because
that's the kind of rule Oh PES move as
black you really start thinking about
equalizing once you get that in
successfully yeah absolutely so she
she's put the night on f8 preparing to
defend the king side and and Fabiana
playing a patient move here Queen to g3
probably White's plan will be involved
building on this tension may be things
like rook F to bringing the other rook
to f1 before before deciding how to deal
with the Kings side maybe eventually
taking on e5 and trying to bust things
open for the rooks what do you think
about that idea and what do you think
blacks plan here is well Glavine still
think again d5 in at some point but it's
gonna be it's gonna be difficult to do
that successfully she's just pleased
with work a7 trying to use her work both
as defense on the seventh ranked and
also maybe shifted to a more useful
square like d7 or f7 rook at three by
Fabiano and as you mentioned doubling
works on the a style of creating some
extra pressure
absolutely and now he goes for Brooke f3
kind of a doubling rook idea not exactly
what I said there but the rook on a7
very nicely placed for Yifan and now she
slides it over to f7 I guess yeah right
no it's it's a position where black is
basically sitting tight and hoping that
hoping that white doesn't have enough
right and I do like the point you
pointed out that if this knight on c3
ever moves d5 is is a shot that okay
even if she doesn't have it right away
it's certainly gonna be a potential
equalizer for black but the problem is
what does she do now and the rooks do
double as we kind of predict it and
black is like us having to figure out a
plan here she comes with the knight to
e6 maybe coming in to d4 yeah commanded
before that this is definitely helpful
note that d5 is always gonna be tough
now because we can just take 185 and
there's a little pin Queen up to us a
little worried about this move because
nobody hits the b6 pawn so now you find
is probably gonna try to play Knight c5
what else right we certainly don't want
to play c5 giving the juicy square to d5
so she's just played and now she's just
kind of sitting tight I don't even know
if it's a reality that she would
actually go for something like b5 maybe
maybe just sort of sitting tight with
the rook and again white's pieces look a
lot better but where is the where's the
beef as they say here comes rookie 3 and
maybe maybe Fabiano's gonna prepare to
open up the F file and try to try to
launch some tactics you phone plays King
h8 to avoid obvious pin issues on the G
file exactly she was done once something
like takes any five and then being
forced to take back with the F on both
players be very focused here Fabiano has
has leaned in past our past our initial
camera angle unfortunately so we're
getting a very good look at his Adam's
apple right now and his uh I guess
that's a teal shirt if that's if that's
a thing you know yeah kind of like my
name
Teil yeah there you go your magic
matching matching Fabiano's shirt today
I think Till's a real color if it's not
just straight-up green or blue I tend to
just make up words but I think teals a
real color so what did you think I'm
sorry do you think he is trying to play
how what's he doing with this move is he
trying to sneak the Commun over to H or
is he just making a move to put pressure
on her time is he trying to play Queen
g3 what do you think I think that's a
good point about the time because
obviously in a position that hasn't had
a lot of fireworks yet that's something
you have to notice it's just who's up on
time and that might be a telling factor
I know I still tend to think that at
some point you're probably gonna rather
take on e5 rather than play f5 because
even though if something like f5 came
you liked the idea of the dark square
diagonal opening up and white being able
to take his time with the attack I feel
like White's not gonna have enough there
so Fabiano maybe just played rookie 4
just to kind of over protect the f4 pawn
so that you fun wasn't wasn't looking to
trade there and and and Bluff it the
ideas of either rook age 4 or Queen h4
okay but she takes anyway is she gonna
take us again okay she is she's playing
quickly and that trade they're
interesting to make that choice well
yeah certainly it looks woeful compared
to the knight on c3 right but again I
guess the idea is that the bishop on a6
is it's kind of maybe long term useful
one of the things that white can't do
here is push a pawn to d4 right you'd
love to have a big Center but you know
then your rook hangs on f1 so perhaps
there's there's gonna be some long-term
value to the bishop on a6 if she can try
to open up the position but I like 92
and the Knights headed to f5 now that's
right Knight f5 via either d4 or g3 but
big question here how does d5 look well
it didn't happen maybe just immediate 94
was too strong
so here's the answer Knights coming to
g3 because now it's also got the
potential of going to h5 to create
pressure I like that I like that a lot
yeah thank you for a lot of players
would play because it comes with the one
move thread and they take c6 but this
Nike 3 is more long-term we
more potential for a night so now that
rookie five saying I don't care if you
play d4 because I'm gonna use my rook to
frontally defend with g5 yeah I like it
it's it's still a position where we have
to like white I'm just waiting for d4 to
come in so why it why isn't Fabiano just
gonna play a move like d4 here and and
then I don't know even c4 to follow and
just try to get a big center we just
started with c4 instead okay interesting
yeah I guess it holds d5 but I still
think the the majority on the queenside
I guess it's not really fully a majority
but I was thinking that d4 would come in
now now we're getting a really close
position long-term you look at all these
pawns on the light squares and think
there's going to be some weaknesses for
that for that Bishop to munch on but the
problem is that there's so many outpost
squares for the night right defy b5 it
looks like white is still in control
here and will likely have the better
minor piece still and note that a
Fabiano is putting all of his squares on
all the pawns on light squares and you
did move his knight back to e2 and
played the move g4 um still not clear
which way is gonna go with that Knight
it's gonna try to stick it on f4 after
we're treating the rook on f3 is he
gonna try to play d4 I'm so many ideas
here ya know now he's able to really
build up it still been a position like
it was the entire game when were white
is kind of patiently taking his time
right he's just gonna build up at his
own leisure reorganized the knight now
he's gonna maybe eventually try for h4
and g5
so you fawn has has definitely been on
her heels since the start of this one on
the black side of the Spanish never
really just has been slightly worse all
game but okay it is blitz and as long as
the game is still going you never know
the biggest worry I have about black
position right now it's starting to be
the time and she's just now crossed
under a minute yeah I really like the
way Fabiano's playing here I think that
if Fabiano's practical abilities and
blitz are just incredible like obviously
not always a wonderful you know elite
player but the also he's doing here
shuffling his pieces around running her
down on the clock while still
maintaining is better position
and not making any commitments like a
lot of strong but not as strong with
players would have played before in that
earlier position but thinking about how
this is for holy pond you don't know
this and you know not having yet who
exactly what he's doing yet but just
knowing that your works nice move there
though that's a practical chance she's
offering the exchange everybody and part
of the reason is that if white takes on
e5 Viviano in many ways is kind of
giving up his his best piece besides the
Queen and and that would allow you Fon
to have an open D file and the potential
to attack the d3 pawn with it so I like
that move rook d8 I'm not sure that
Fabiano is gonna bite my guess is white
just continues along the path that we've
been talking about gen and tries to
organize g5 at some point you could even
you could even do something crazy like
run your King over to one of these dark
squares like f2 before putting the the
other work on g1 and and just try to
punch g5 through and have all of White's
pieces in a mating attack on the other
hand why not if you if we take on e5 and
you take G takes e5 when we play rook x3
and we're trying to break something open
with g5
okay he played g5 immediately mm-hmm
interesting now after Knight takes d5
well this looks so scary doesn't it yeah
it still looks like white is white is
just getting closer to something
something crushing here I mean this is
almost start to look like a problem book
mate right you got the night on g5 and
the rooks gaining toward f8 moves like
Queen f3 just threatened mate right away
with threats like rook f8 so super scary
stuff for you Fon here and she only has
30 seconds to figure it out so Queen
Knight f3 hitting the rip on on e5 and
also hitting the bishop on g6 it looks
like Bobby's gonna I mean yeah holy
fines gonna be compelled to play rook e6
what she did do rook h1 and and that
means we're about to switch right here
comes the Queen back to h3 with this
rook guarding the F file that's a mating
net and I'm starting to think we're
about to see our first decisive result
here this is getting this is getting
really rough okay so Queen h3 now rook
takes a f4 holds on because right but
Fabiana I just has so many moves in his
disposal right rook g4 is a move in
between even even bring the knight back
to g5 and and try to try to wiggle your
way towards some kind of meeting that
that way I think that okay Brooke aged
four maybe not threatening mate now with
moves like rook h8 there's gonna be king
of seven but with this Knight coming in
to g5 looks like Black has a lot of
problems look at the time though I mean
to you Fonz credit she's been worse all
game and and and Fabiano hasn't put her
away yet as he now gets under thirty
seconds
and here's this move e5 okay looks like
a good move because next what's gonna
happen is if you take 45 working a check
and then Knight takes e5 jack and we're
gonna be winning material because of the
hanging bishop on g6 and that is what's
been playing yeah there's gonna be rook
f2 or Queen e2 in the end so the issue
there is I'm sure fabiana's calculated
that but but he's got to find a way to
gobble up this bishop without allowing
there to become some sort of counter
play against his King on g2 and looks
like he's kind of figured out how to do
that there's no checks now and I think
with rook h8 check coming you fun we'll
be throwing in the towel here
momentarily
yeah after Queen b6 it seems like
anything should be good here for her
Fabi I need to play rook e1 Jack um but
a simple Queen trade OB will do as they
say and now it's a matter of technique
and I'm sure that that make oh he missed
it but okay
Vaughn decides that she's gonna resign
anyway and game one is is in the book so
so that's uh that's where we stand now
is everyone can see the score one to
nothing in favor of the American
Grandmaster Fabiano Caruana the and now
we have another Lopez so is this gonna
be one of those one of those days Jen
where we all learn a little more theory
about one particular opening than we
ever planned on well yeah it seems like
this is I mean this is going to be an
opening that we see a lot from them this
was the game that wholly fund one
against Fabiana um yeah I got a throw
that in the grand cage has classic she
actually did defeat him in that game
underdog here but she's really been kind
of crushing lately in deal especially
that was her maybe maybe the best result
of her career besides winning the World
Championship title what would you say is
that is that a fair thing winning Beale
I think it was up there right certainly
a huge result for her and that was just
just a month and a half ago exactly so
it's very inspiring indeed like have a
woman right now playing at her level
it's just we would love to see more
women playing at her level but it really
is exciting Danny yeah absolutely I mean
she's she's uh seems to be on her way to
being the great the great predecessor
that's a Judah Pogue are at least many
many hope so and she's obviously playing
better chess than most people on the
planet can aspire to so we'll see how
she how she fares and her her her Lopez
where she gets to be white right now I
don't know this this is a much more open
position than the last one we had white
in the Lopez for the unusual on before
and the center already huge for it's
unusual good oh there's just a little
bit of congestion with the rest of her
development right because I can't move
her night yet right now and she wants
the it or Bishop out so why not play for
a three and put the questions that
Bishop yeah it makes sense and Fabiano
sort of sensing his opportunity to take
advantage of that you highlighted that
the knight can't move because of the
rook but if the knight can't move that
means the bishop can't get out and sort
of the the snowball effect here and so
Fabiana are trying to take advantage of
the dysfunctional development with a
move like c5 so opening up the position
while while white is kind of struggling
for optional coordination makes sense
though yeah and I but I like your movie
a3 I think that I almost like b4 here
just just play d4 and and I wonder if
there's a way to to sacrifice the Queen
side pawn and try to use the center as
some sort of compensation
I love it I mean that's what I was
thinking too because it's so frustrating
that you can just play Bishop a5 like no
you shouldn't be able to get away
without her right well and she does it
all right
it's uh not sure if it's theory and it's
always scary whenever they play a move
that we recommend because I personally
don't think very highly of my moves but
there you go okay but but I like
Nightbeat in fact that's even better
than the follow up I was thinking now
she's able to gobble back the pawn and
maintain her large center and it looks
like white is on her way to a pretty
decent edge in this middle game yeah
you're absolutely right that night b3
move was sweet because if you do retreat
we would be able to take in and play
Bishop d2 yep so 94 trying to contest
the diagonal that's super strong Bishop
on c2 but still a super accurate follow
up to that night to c5 really puts the
question to black he doesn't want to
remove this night from it's super strong
center post as that would reopen the
bishop on the long b1 h7 diagonal but he
also doesn't want to take the knight
with the bishop because then he loses
the bishop pair so I really like this
move and I see five and we can see on
the clock that you fawn is in a better
position than she was in Game one here
not with a big advantage but a small
time advantage rather than being down by
a minute or two yeah and then Bishop a5
immediately from Aviano and now what's
the yeah if g4 greedy g4 yeah I want the
greedy g4 for sure she's playing patient
Chester Brook comes to a three there was
a 19-3 in the position huh so I guess
that was why which and then you take on
c2 and move your back of knight back to
e4 right
yeah nice point there that would have
been that would have been a very nice
tempo for for black so she plays rook a
three but here comes b6 that's a very
common way to undermine an overextended
Center everybody you you go after that
lead pawn so that when the capture
happens here black can probably take
with the a pawn or the Queen and already
be getting more more squares for his
pieces so so b6 a nice move by Fabiano
and we're reaching a critical moment
here gen where I I think for white to
maintain an edge there has to be some
sort of aggressive move here coming yeah
four no we have to check g4 at this
point as well all right
it looks really risky but I guess the
point is that after G for Bishop
retreats you can't really just take one
of you for twice because see five hands
at the end yep
oh that's what Fabiano is banking on and
I love the way Fabiano's plains so
actively in this position because I do
think Bishop before it takes any for
working for it's pretty greedy because
we also have this move like Bishop d5
just kind of capitalizing on all the
lights where's yeah
so I don't think that whole funds gonna
snap that pawn right now I think she's
gonna do something different like yeah
should take some b6 now I think well I
think we'll see you probably play queen
cakes b6 or what do you think you think
he's gonna kick with the pond well no I
like Queen takes b6 better as well just
because of the pressure that the queen
is able to exert on the d4 pawn and it
makes it to me even harder for for a
white to open the center but yeah you
made a great point there as much as we
like G for you know Bobby was banking on
the fact that if a trade happened on e4
the the light squirts would have become
a real problem for for white as well as
as well as the D pawn so just showing
everybody that line here that you were
just talking about but I'm starting to
I'm starting to feel like Fabiano has
kind of worked his way out of the worst
of it maybe white is still doing okay
but it's hard to see how her how her
pieces get any more active okay here's
Knight - D - that's interesting
trying to force her to change but we
maybe we can try Knight to e5 here just
keeping lots of pieces in the board and
all of a sudden blacks got like three
attackers four attackers the knight on
g6 bishop on e6 and the Queen
potentially coming in I guess the nice
thing is that we're gonna be three
defends everything laterally so maybe
thank you guys not such a good move but
I don't know I honestly I'm starting to
like black yeah me too
it and also the time is the time has
sort of shifted right we've gone from an
advantage for white now she's down a
little bit on the clock and this is just
amazing though I mean Fabiano just plays
so incredibly well it's like you really
see it when you see him playing against
slightly lower rated player rather than
playing blitz for instance in the same
with rapid and blitz
where he was playing against like knock
on the bond right because I mean just
way he's playing this game like a little
bit worse somehow and now just like all
these super active moves which is
turning the tables on holy pond
yeah and 94 followed by his willingness
to give up that dark square bishop that
was key and okay so now she's she's
taken e4 but everybody she can't take
twice as that would allow this rook on
b3 to be captured by the bishop so
that's right I'm guessing rook a 3 will
be the move here trying to do a double
attack on on either the pawn on a7 and
the pawn on e4
although sliding the rook all the way
over to g3 is also on my mind if I did
ever have outside a chances for an
attack but okay no she she plays the the
safer more logical let's have a double
attack on the pollens move good for
right it just seems easier to play for
black and away because we've got like
some activity um
like if I were to play well I was
thinking at what c4 and then if you play
working for and had Bishop c5 but it
just was very scary to me for for right
so if I straight away and you still
can't really tape on anymore because we
could take twice and just snap the pawn
off 185 because it was a peon on the D
file and I was gonna say I think that
that's kind of a key idea there because
what we've got is the potentially weak
dark squares as really the I'm sorry the
light scores is really a bigger problem
for you fawns position the King side may
be coming under fire and so you know if
you went took a7 which she's going to
I'm immediately looking at both Queen h4
and Knight h4 somebody's going to h4 and
you start to get worried about White's
King they're exactly I mean that all
dates back to g4 which makes it a
classical game especially you're trying
to like win upon right is very scary in
these blitz games to weakened your King
because there's this relentless pressure
so Rick a7 was full you fons choice and
as you mentioned you gotta watch out for
night h4 yeah and these positions always
make you wish you could just move the
pawn from from g4 back to g2 but as much
as you try the darn chest comm software
the buggy chest outcome software doesn't
let you play G for Chi 2 so now the the
king is the king of
open and there's no turning back I think
Fabiano's gonna turn the tables real
quick and we're gonna have a huge attack
on the Kings side but this versity three
is better than Knight h4 because the
problem a takes whereas it was taking
away that idea that we don't know of
taking on e5 at the end of the variation
right and it takes the square for the
Queen and I think there's there's
definitely several positions where maybe
the Queen comes to h4 and you just play
moves like h5 at some point I think the
black has a lot of ways to try to start
to pry open the the white king but
here's how you find quickly playing a
good defensive move to defend her third
rank work III immediately
now our phurba ship takes III Knight
does get into h4 an e4 is no longer
under attack but if you panic mode now
Danny because this is really scary now
you come into f3 with check but I guess
the problem is where's the follow-up
because I like this move Bishop a4 as
counter play here the thing is that as
scary as this looks I'm I'm not you know
Queen h4 has no concrete threat even
lifting the rook to a move like d6
would have a ton of risk on on the back
rank so I'm wondering if if you fawn can
get some counter play on the Queen side
black might just settle on a perpetual
like Knight h4 check and Knight back to
f3 check cos because where's the where's
the concrete follow-up here for black to
make White's King feel really in danger
that's a good question in a way you
would like a move like h5 probably try
to open up some work some more line than
creating g4 as a weakness yeah and I
like Bishop b3 because if she can trade
the d5 Bishop then the e4 pawn obviously
is there is Queen b6 but then there's
Bishop takes d5 Queen a7 Bishop g4 and I
think that who you find will grieve a
sigh of relief to get that pawn and that
would be that would be a phenomenal
exchange sac so ok Fabiana plays age 5
and we quickly see the exchange but but
still I guess outside of the g4 pawn
becoming weaker once this exchange
happens we still don't see a we still
don't see a a way to to get in to get an
aggressive attack against the White King
right because this move queen bee ones
pretty sweet make I'm freezing my queen
on defy if I like that move yep very
important although I like I guess what's
going on with me for we still can't take
it cuz I guess you had mean do you want
or something yeah look at this move
queen b7 super aggressive I like it even
King g3 here ok she finds Queen d7 to
defend the pawn but but King to g3 I'm
thinking that black doesn't really have
any enough and if you if you try to get
more pieces involved well I was queen h7
was played I was wondering what was
happening on f5 Oh Bishop f4 defending
against the ideas of invasion in 91
immediately by Fabi yeah this is getting
super sharp here is he gonna check on
him 3 and trade the Bishop for the
knight no he wants to keep the mating
net alive and that's agree and it's like
dizzying the path of this Knight isn't a
crazy actually looks like mate all of a
sudden amazingly in that position after
93 there was no way to stop Queen e1
well I'll have to go over that one again
but what's funny in performance by
Fabiano Keira Knightley yes you might
from these first two games you might
think wow this is a mismatch but really
it's that v you played amazing it's not
that who you find played poorly that was
no it absolutely and I I'm surprised
still that it turned around so quickly
for black because I do think white was
better I think she had defended the
attack well just to show everybody on
this little analysis board here at
Bishop d2 Queen f3 check in Queen takes
f2 was gonna be mate and of course if
Bishop to e3 to guard f2 then Queen e1
was made on the spot so 93 just came out
of nowhere
bye-bye Fabiano and and suddenly
suddenly you found was lost so alright
here we are in our first he's trying to
take a leaf out of Levon Aronian book
playing a very soft like yesterday Levon
played many of these positions although
this is looks like it's on the road to
transposing to something a little more
traditional
Queen's Indian like maybe even Queen's
Gambit like if black eventually plays d5
here so not going to be a traditional
Varys off but but an obscure start by d4
and Bishop a forum of two
yeah so we're obviously but this is a
really tough start for whole you fine it
kind of makes you wish that there was
like a little time for her to breathe
you know like a like a break that's one
of the things about these speed chess
matches you don't get any time yep it
over tilt so I hope that she can kind of
calm herself and really bring the bass
than the rest of the mat yeah and that's
and that's the worry especially if you
are sort of the underdog and you know
you want to have confidence as you're
playing if you lose the first two your
first goal now is to kind of stop the
bleeding right maybe you get a draw even
obviously you've taken one if you can
get it but the main goal is here is to
get on the board and you don't want the
match to get into the three four game
territory so we'll see how she can hold
her on here and now we've got definitely
a weird-looking Queens Indian defense
yeah that last game I'm still like I'm
still really enthralled by it I just
like think it's really incredible how
well these elite grandmasters playing
just blitz games it's like some of these
moves and concepts that they come up
with it's like a classical game you
would be so proud to come up with that
right no I mean I would I don't know
that I'm whatever yeah of course a class
of any game right any game would be
happy but no we've all it's always been
impressive as these matches we do online
have gotten bigger and bigger names and
more and more elite players it's it's
amazing to see you know the way they're
able to play even when they're living
off just the increment and even in
bullets oh and we run the numbers
afterwards we have these stats on our
site that we we run and and and use
called cap statistics honor if you've
ever seen those Jen where we basically
it's sort of a system we developed where
we can see the accuracy of players
regardless of the result and how they
compare against each other and we've
seen some really incredible high level
performances and these blitz matches
where these guys are playing superhuman
chests and and better than they do in
short sports over the board so just
amazing stuff alright so we've got a
bishop situation here oh you find just
played this move Knight h5 so that she
can kind of get a stake in her centers
want to just whip Fabi play e4 and have
everything he wants with the Juba shops
yeah it's a position right I mean I know
I was maybe sound like I was being
dramatic to say was an obscure Queen
zinnia but it is right I mean this is
like you don't see the bishop on it for
normally you don't see Knights on H five
nights on h3 and moves like g3 at some
parts of this structure to look normal
like almost an Enzo Indian right like a
classical NIM to Indian with the Queen
on c3 but but many other parts of it are
just really awkward and I think White
has a small edge but but Yvonne's
position seems comfortable as well Wahby
yeah this is waving a flag but I see
that normally we would think that the
move a3 was weakening but fabi's thought
maybe is it's easier for me to crank
open things on that it is for you to
crank things open on liking right yeah
totally in fact it's hard to play a move
like c5 and that's maybe why she played
Queen to e8 because the D file would
have been pinned and it's she plays
Queen e8 and maybe that also prepares a
move like b5 coming to try to open up
some avenues against the the White Queen
side but but I agree it's this is gonna
maybe turn into a much more dynamic game
than I thought white can't play g4 yet
because after captures the the pawn on
on f3 is pinned to the bishop on g2 but
at some point why it's gonna want to
play moves like g4 and try to start
opening up things yeah or maybe I'm also
wondering if he wants to revert to the
idea of playing before moving moving his
bishop and then sticking and the pawn on
e4 so this this is just such an unusual
position and Karin is actually getting
into some time pressure here Holy
Fathers got a minute edge which is
encouraging because a lot of times when
you start losing you have trouble with
managing your
yep 4x8 by Fabi yeah now we get to stick
our Bishop on f4 and one go and and
maybe even go for efore I'm wondering if
I was harping on g4 as a way to open up
the G file but perhaps white just
switches gears and and tries to go big
in the center with a move like efore
yeah hell is taking twice and playing
like a 5 maybe that was it looks like
Bobby is tight kind of shaky taking a
positional approach here though he's
played to move d5 and now a quick night
a 5 from who you find maintaining her
big-time edge after king b1 though I'm
wondering if you found can get away with
a move like a 5 here and after the
bishop moves even some sort of long-term
plan where you where you bring the
knight in to b3 and to c5 maybe try for
efore and and positionally we've got
we've got a positional battle now not
something where the kings are going for
checkmate oh I really like this move
Bishop a6 this is more so Indian style
this system is great yeah what do we do
ya know the c4 pawn is a real problem
and suddenly something Fabiano's got
issues here yeah he's got issues not the
good kind because work before leads to
e5 so do we have to if we take then
after Queen e6 work before there's
there's three guys on c4 we get away
with maybe just playing I mean I notice
that if I play C 5 yeah
well among the problems if if I can even
take with the b-pawn right because you
can't actually take the knight on a5 due
to some sort of discover checks on the
Queen yeah that doesn't look very good
at all so if I were you going for some
compactable chances here I think he's
played Tate phanie 6 yeah I was gonna
say she can probably even just take c4
first and the e6 pawn is it's kind of
overextended not going anywhere and I
think we're we're in big trouble if
you're in camp Caruana because you're
down a minute you're down double the
time and and about to be facing some
sort of massive assault on the light
squares of the queen of the Queen side
with the bishop and the night I think
probably Queen takes c6 just makes a lot
of sense here pretty easy move to play
finds a better one but when we take c6
even threatens things like Bishop 8 to
check gen and all of a sudden there's
crazy
it looks disastrous here for Fabiano
because not only is his
using a pond but it's King as it seems
to be less safe and blacks pieces are
actually well poised on c4 and i-5 yep
and she's actually four why not I guess
take you for first but and you know some
Fabi desperate to stop this idea of the
Queen coming to e6 but but there's gonna
be other problems here I mean among them
moves like Bishop e2 come in mind if you
take up three there's there's an F pawn
and a bishop on c4 Gardening f1 so you
don't want to let that guy live for very
long probably Queen takes f3 needs to be
played Queen takes that's three with the
idea that g5 could be met my queen g4
right yeah and you're hanging on and
back position so I still wonder if she
should have taken e6 instead of taking
me for just because that throat of
Bishop e2 but I mean black is still
totally in control here and all right
Queen c2 I mean can't black go go get
some material if he wants
you mean with Bishop to b3 yeah
apparently on Queen takes f3 one of the
easiest moves was Queen to g6 check oh
yeah and then it was just mate White's
white she was uh you know something like
there should be three mate I guess Queen
to c7 is there but then Queen do g6
check comes again and I just I feel like
white is what is on the verge of either
losing the Queen or getting mated so so
Bishop e3 looks okay to me and another
move you might play is something like b5
or d5 to kind of anchor in the bishop on
that Square if you want to have more
mobility with your knight but I think
white is white is in big trouble again
the only worry here gen is you Vaughn is
taking a lot of time right so you
definitely you know you want to see if
you're if she's looking to score here
you want to see her get something and
not get into a massive time scramble she
was trying to find a super accurate move
in this position and she's played Queen
h5 ignoring the very obvious but should
be three and instead trying to better
that and now after Bishop b3
five question is has his backfired and
off her hers it's still just really good
I can just yeah I was gonna say can he
just take a c7 and I mean f2 was
possible there cuz the Queen was
overloaded f2 is also a threat again in
this position we do yeah and she just
wormed her queen into H three ideas that
she's not really worried about g5 and
but instead Fabia's quickly played
working on he's still at a major time
deficiency here yep
well now rookie two can be played
transition the F pawn into an e pawn
yeah she goes for that that looks pretty
accurate and and I think I think she's
gonna go on to score here it looks like
this is getting more and more dangerous
b5 can be played now just to defend the
defend the threats of maybe the Queen on
this diagonal they're still mission b3
but she's looked it sa trying to create
some threats also notice the bookwork on
24 is hanging immediate Queen d7
from Fabiana down on time he's got to
play fast what about just Queen g2 here
is it possible for the black Queen to
just come to the to the second rank and
and force White's hand there you're
saying there's no threats here for right
I mean I would agree you find scamp but
he's losing a little bit for a time
advantage yeah that's what I was
thinking
although okay she finds maybe an even
more straightforward way to to punch
things through I mean now there's
there's millions and moves here
including King h8 and there's yeah she
goes I think that's the most simple way
to take care of business here go get a
queen on f1 and and I think Fabiana is
just gonna throw in the towel to be
honest yeah there he goes well I hope
nobody wrote not only that she wins with
black and so if she if she has a good as
good of a game as she did the first time
is white where I think she did pretty
well she could be in position to level
the score here and we have 50 minutes
left in the Kalama clock so that
still plenty of time here in the five
minute portion for those of you just
joining us welcome to the 2017 speech
Chess Championship the don't cuss icon
site in the in the nimzo-indian yeah
that was that was definitely ambitious
you know it felt like five you had such
success in the first few games he was
trying to kind of like have like an
absolutely wipe out and it backfired but
I think that's that's for good that's
good for us because you know making a
match a little bit tighter yeah he
pushed his luck there a little bit with
that super aggressive Queen side castles
there but once Bishop a6 came on the
board it was like Oh White has problems
so what do we have here we've got a
French no longer an e5 moved by black so
first time we've seen a French we'll see
if it's the last I think if you if white
gets a big win here I'm always biased
against the French I always feel like
white is just better in the French and
even when their knives I think that's a
problem I need to work on but anyway I
like white here I like the threat of f5
coming but okay this is a pretty typical
tirage French and I guess black has
plenty of play on the Queen side moves
like Bishop a6 or gonna appear on the
board and and we have a game yeah very
close game which is always fun to see
him bliss because and it starts to get
wild just when the both of the players
only have like two minutes on the clock
or one minute on the clock so I like to
see that and I think that um it's a
great decision by Bobby I know I think
this won't be the last French so we see
this match so you play the French then
no I don't like it at all I don't like
playing against it either I like so I
think it's a wise choice for a player
who really likes tactics and who just
beat you on in a real nice ball game
right well now the Knights coming into
c4 so white puts the kibosh on that idea
but the problem with b3 is is really
that it undermines the c3 pawn so in a
lot of variations now as many know that
the idea and the French is once black
has established this big pawn chain you
want to undermine the dark square pawns
and and get all the space you could ask
for over there so I don't know if
B takes c3 isn't necessarily right away
GN okay he plays it I was gonna say
maybe even Bishop a6 first but you
suddenly start to see that b3 is is a
move again like we wish we could play
back right we wish we could play b3 b2
in a lot of positions but now now I
think the darks words are gonna start to
fall apart here for white okay still
white White's doing fine Bishop a6 bring
the rook over to c1 or d1 rook F -
apparently so we're just like playing
out maybe maybe black has a new target
on be free with something like a for
coming and in a position after after
there after dealing with this pressure
here maybe Queen to d7 but I think at
some point maybe black tries to play a4
and open up new lines for the Queen side
this is an interesting position where
it's it has started to open off you
notice there's all sorts of different
ideas here
for black like playing on the C file
playing for a4 maybe you know playing
for a piece coming into b3 so there's
kind of a lot to think about here for
black yeah
and he's thinking about it time is about
even but uh yeah I mean I'd be forced
looking better and better if you can
bring the knight to b4 and have threats
like Knight to d3 it's official somehow
late wearing a new one I guess once I go
to b3 I can always consider coming back
to c5 and e4 right so yeah and I guess
the main thing is you got to deal with
the threat on c6 either way either
defend the knight or move the knight at
this point and I don't think black wants
to trade and bring White's bishop to d4
yeah that's like a gorgeous spot for
your bishop because it does everything
defend your knight on c3 it stops it he
puts pressure on my knight on me sex oh
wow all right as we say that Fabiana
goes for it I guess we'll see what the
follow-up is well he probably just did a
night night before but yeah let's work
c8 immediately now what are we gonna do
after it just like Queenie free or
something and I keep coming back to
wondering if Y can get punch f5 through
I mean every time you do it it you're
all in on the attack and and maybe e5
becomes more vulnerable and this is
situation you might also open up the
bishop on g5 but at some point white
white wants to try to get aggressive on
the kingside so she plays Queen e3 here
I like that battery and I I I wonder how
long it's gonna take before she tries to
start getting back to some sort of
counter play on the Kings side yes I
like this Queen is right three move
creating getting some control and then
and then thinking about your move f5 f5
mate now is still met by Bishop g5 and
maybe that's what she doesn't like she
doesn't what doesn't want that Bishop
coming in and posing an awkward question
to the Queen so rook d1 rook D one's
nice I mean there may be tactics at some
point of bringing the Knight to e4 if
the Queen remains on d8 okay getting out
of the way and now there's now yeah okay
f5 comes I mean this is what this is
what white wants to do here the Queen's
gonna either go to e1 or f3 okay I'd
like you one better and one of the big
problems here for every everyone is that
if the e6 pawn just sits then okay
clearly it's a big target now but if you
ever take a five White's probably
capturing on d5 and not even taking back
on f5 right away which is kind of a key
point just like black tried to undermine
the C and the D pawns everybody that's
what White's trying to do with f5 by
undermining a six is maybe this D pawn
becomes a problem so so I like White's
chances if she can somehow open up some
play here on the light squares probably
taking e6 is something I want to do
rather than trying to push f6 Jen what
do you think yeah I agree I mean I think
it's we want to keep some open lines
with our pieces are really well placed
is why if opens up or just I think just
maintain the tension because taking an
f5 looks like a real bad idea for VI
so rather than the commit tactics I
think I want to maintain the tension but
how do i improve my position here is
like that that's the question and you
know those bishops are doing a good job
of controlling to really piece where's
the ones on g5 and n e6 right
yeah I agree well she's gone into a
think here and so the risk that is
obviously she only has two minutes now
about forty seconds behind on the clock
go ahead oh I'm gonna say 52 is a really
interesting move because it put some
ideas and takes me 500 patients and also
there's this h4 followed by a cook g4
I'm switching from a piece attack on the
Kings side to a pawn storm yeah I like I
really like the threat of h4 that's nice
because if black just makes some sort of
natural move here everybody h4 comes and
I said no f6 but if the bishop came back
to e7 and you could punch a move like f6
through with tempo suddenly black black
had some problems and I think Fabiano
may be kind of you know senses senses
yeah that yeah so he plays King h8 and I
expect the bishop to go all the way back
to d8 now okay no he's gonna invite it
he's inviting f6 I guess he's saying
that if you play f6 I can take and I've
now I've now cleared the G file with my
last move so suddenly the g3 pawn and
the move like rook GA coming in maybe
maybe he's okay another possibility in
all these situations were constantly
having to be visual enough I guess right
now it still doesn't work that well
because you can just take take and play
Queen b8 and then after f6 I don't know
you have to analyze that situation yeah
I'm looking at it right now as you're as
you're talking about it for the fans and
I agree with you this is super dynamic
because after f6 takes even if I move
like Bishop d6 you have 97 coming in and
that Knight can't be captured without
opening up the bishop on d4 for a
discovered check so I would bet that
she's thinking about your Bishop takes
d5 idea here gen that looks it's the
kind of Alwyn move I would play probably
a little bit too quickly okay she
decides to go for something more solid
but yeah but I think that was an
interesting shot for sure yeah well she
still has an attack here without
sacrificing a piece so that's probably
what you think right now the 93 is under
capture so for which it seems like
there's a wrong direction Danny I agree
I something feels like that last moment
was a critical moment whether it was
Bishop takes d5 or something else but
the moment the minor pieces start to get
traded everybody you start to believe in
Black's attack a little less and I'm
sorry White's attack a little this yeah
and
yeah and also the night just going to a
for when you really want it somehow
participating in an attack cuz that's
where your advantages and note now that
um we've got up some issues on e5 so
that's why we find cleats we work e1 you
know it's not like wait I just don't
like wait as much as I like to wait
before yeah agreed
so I'm you know mmm you could consider
the move Bishop b5 thinking that after
he removes that night on a for their
moves like works III and Queen c5 trying
to kind of encroach into her position so
who you find has played queen F word the
King side attack is still on the menu
yeah I guess you may come back to trying
to get f6 right we're taking on e6
because you can't take back with a pawn
because there's Queen takes f8 mating ah
that's nice yeah we'll see if he if he
misses that but assuming Fabiano doesn't
doesn't miss that tactic it you know
it's the attack is on but over the last
few moves I'm starting to get a feel
like black as an accurate defensive move
or two away toward the C file becoming
the main thing and and he also has this
past D pawn on d5 so starting to get a
little more worried for White's position
here but but Fabiano struggling to find
something against this threat ends up
settling on Queen to d8 that's right
because this would be for a four we
might have grown in take some you sixes
in between those so far yeah shutting it
down that particular idea guarding the
rook on f8 okay no Queen before now
she's trying to get her Knight back into
play with Knight c3 that and i donate
for so horribly offsides
yeah and if I was Fabiano I would look
for a chance to take that night and then
continue to simplify out the position
okay Queen Queen d7 also a good
potential threat because now there's
ideas like Queen coming in to c5 may be
coming in to before and I think if we if
you get the Queen's off the board here
if you're black all your worries about
getting checked made it go away and you
can now focus on your past d5 pawn and
the open C file so okay some treaties in
the game now cakes and I know that
you never play workout one week of a
can take on f1 finally decided
which way to recapture here well it
doesn't look like we got me any strong
ideas on eat on d5 at the set at the
moment maybe I can play 94 though just
improve the position of my night we
don't I like this move 94 the main point
everybody is if it's captured Queen
takes d7 is much better for white so
okay she doesn't go for that I wonder
why because to me the night might have
been able to head into d6 and and have a
nice outfit squared but okay she's
heading into f4 where she can hit the e6
pawn yeah Fabiano says no thank you
gets rid of that night but now now we're
in a time scramble the the first real
test where a close to equal position
with both sides under with very little
time on the clock we'll see who manages
themselves better here yeah I was gonna
say that I like pawns chances well I
don't know who I like here I mean I like
the bishop versus the night because the
e6 pawn is on the light square but the
but the e5 pawn is also hanging right
now and in a number of other positions
and but look at that King I mean that
super-sized King of Hawaii fine yeah and
with the pawn on b3 stopping anything
from contesting that yeah that was a
super strong idea you could tell foggy
on a pause to think if he could get away
with taking the e5 pawn because you're
not happy letting that King come all the
way to d4 and an endgame like this yeah
but she's got two seconds on the clock
yeah wow she played she played that move
with literally 0.4 seconds as she went
she went from 0.4 to 2.4 so that was a
that was a problem there and now she's
continuing to be under fire here
literally living off the increment yeah
I define accurate moves Bishop takes a
d5 isn't move here she do it she doesn't
go for it yeah I think there probably
would have been some kind of reasonable
dependence there but now just came
community you before doesn't seem that
strong anymore there's always she's
gonna lose the 5-pound but she does get
the B for pass pawn this is okay this is
should be winning for black with the to
pass pawns but I don't know if it's so
simple
see if there's if there's some kind of
way to get counter play with the b-pawn
before the two passed pawns brought up
the board but it looks like Fabiano is
getting there just in time yeah I mean
the pawns are so strong running in
another tempo Wow well what's happening
okay he's all lit he's got to sacrifice
the brook looks like she has no choice
likely calculating and realizing
probably that the pawns are gonna be too
much for the tower yeah this is yeah
with that came coming so powerful just a
few moves ago now at the opposite right
way yeah but fantastic technique there
by Fabiano finding a way to to patiently
patiently poke and prod and in the end I
think time was as much of a factor in
that victory for Fabiano as the as the
board you fought just didn't have enough
time to continue finding accurate moves
in that in that dynamic endgame wow this
is just so funny because you know I just
I just did commentary on the st. Louis
rapid and blitz where there was like 10
minute breaks between H blitz game and
some of the players were saying like
that's a bit too long because it's hard
for them to get the momentum when
they're doing well this is the exact
opposite there's like zero second break
right I love it it's it's just fun to
think about these psychological impact
here of the Blitz but honestly I think
both players are not at all upset with
their play because even though he founds
down one out of four she's played some
play some good shafts there's been like
really zero horrible blunder so far
right so I hope that both of their
confidence will be high and we'll
continue to see great games well we have
a another slightly obscure Queens pawn
game as far as the move order goes you
don't you don't see both sides giving up
the their Bishop this early in the game
or sorry black giving up the dark square
Bishop and Nell now White has kind of
like a nimzo-indian again where you've
you know you played Queen c2 and Queen
takes c3 like a classical NIMS oh but
but not a traditional approach from
black so just strange yeah this is the
interesting structure they've now played
a couple times why I would have
thing I think it's a great idea for who
you find to play this again because
maybe Fabio will just queenside castle
again because I turned out so poorly for
him last time you were in this variation
right yeah hoping that he'll be stubborn
and go for something hyper aggressive
and give her a chance to get to get her
game going but I think it's gonna look a
little different this down and we it
looks like we've got a lot of superstars
and the chat as always I saw your your
co-hosts from yesterday I Anna ruled off
online as well as brand math we've been
flying all so it's great to see the kind
of international attention that these
feed just matches command banning yeah I
I like I like you phone's position and I
think strategically a little bit bias
just cuz I play in nimzo-indian as black
often but it feels like the closed
position is gonna be okay she's gonna
play a move like b6 here and strive for
Bishop basics again similar to last game
the Queen on f6 is a little weird right
you don't normally see that and now she
has to play Bishop d7 to guard the a4
pawn is there some outside chances that
that Queen on f6 gets in trouble at
Bishop c5 comes in and something crazy
no no Bobby on Oh says I'm just gonna
play c5 here and counter play on the
Queen side and where is his king
planning to go they're planning to just
chill in the center because if she wants
to she can try it should be five they're
stopping castle inning but has a way to
go to castle as well and Bobby could
always change his mind and stick his
Bishop back on B 397 it's just strange
to me cuz I keep thinking that okay he
doesn't go for it again
but I mean was there a reason why you
you don't want to go for something with
Bishop g5 and and takes on e7 to take
away the right castle maybe there was
something like queen g6 Bishop e7 queen
g2 in between no cuz there was rook g1
in that line and the Queen is guarding
then I don't have three it was yeah
you're right
maybe yeah I don't know that i don't
know the reason for that with right away
after after Fabiano chooses not to play
Bishop g5 and go for that line you fawn
says not gonna give you another chance
and actually played the move h6 to stop
Bishop g5 so I don't know interesting
there but I think that it's hard
sometimes to calculate the tactics when
the pieces are on obscure positions even
if the structure is something you've
kind of seen before you don't normally
see tactics with the bishop coming to g5
and and you know skewering a queen at
night on e7 at least not and blitz so
you maybe sometimes miss opportunities
hey 960 yet but you're talking like we
add I know it seems that way right I
mean that's some of the pieces in this
in this line are just not normal but now
now it's very this move between g6
allows us to placate 76 and 95
potentially yeah that's a
straightforward tactic that would win a
pawn at the end of the line you have to
look at Bishop h3 though with the g2
pawn being pinned to the king and and
maybe actually looks like well I'm
really good yeah black maybe gets enough
enough of an attack there but I'm sure
Fabiana was calculating something like
that right now that's right so you would
just so basically what you're saying is
just take tokay I see your analysis
board you take slice on g6 and then play
just h3 right immediately you can't play
Queen takes d6 because a Bishop c5 so
instead it looks like fabi's kind of
kind of prepare that potentially for the
future right
rook c1 bishop h3 is no longer any good
now I think white can just play moves
like either 91 or even Knight h4 and and
black doesn't get what he wants
out of that or what she wants out of
that so but but it seems like you fought
has some things to figure out here I
mean you start to see the knight on a5
is weird the d6 pawn is under fire okay
she goes for Bishop h3 and 91 but I
don't think it solves all of blacks
problems of having some weird things
going on I mean the a4 pawn is just
hanging now all right well that means
she's all in she plays f5 and she's
trying to get an attack yeah that's
right she's trying to just play f4
Bishop g2
and then f3 what a what do we do against
that once you once we get our pawn to f4
I guess you can just play f3
so that's one of the reasons why Fabia
played this move Bishop b6
yeah I like it without having to be
provoked to it with that for which would
create some really exciting tactical
possibilities
now of course to middle to late because
you just close the shop down with that
three right not even calculating Bishop
takes a five from G to Knight G to F for
a yeah no I think you just play a3 and
this looks like a Kings Indian gone
wrong for black white is way ahead of
the race and having broken through on
the Queen side it looks like you fawns
gonna have way too many problems to
figure out here yeah for last move
before recapturing on d6 I wonder but
yeah something to think about maybe
there was just a take on e7 or something
was probably just good yeah yeah yeah no
but you're right though it's something
to look at because realizing the
position is now sort of desperate for
black she has to find something ultra
aggressive to to keep the balance
otherwise I think this is almost over
okay she's she's just gonna give up the
pawn I I think here Fabiano's debating
between either Brooks e7 or Coyne takes
b3 because Queen takes b3 is not bad it
also threatens the bishop on h3 over
there but but if you could play rook to
c7 maybe that's even more accurate and
continue to stay aggressive or maybe
seven is another possibility right
there's it seems like there's hardly any
attacking potential for black because
this only idea that I can see well maybe
there's also me for as well and then I
don't know it's really slow but takes on
e4 and like Knight f5 or something yeah
because ever be definitely can't do it's
out of the question when you can shut
down the party with f3
yeah but I with ideas of taking on e4
and I and I still think that after
looking at those options I feel like
Queen takes b3 just makes even more
sense it seems like the best move
because you threatened to take the
bishop on h3 with the Queen and then if
Bishop c4 then you have it okay looks
like we're getting that line yeah yeah I
think wing takes b3 made the most sense
there and
as much as we would like to stay
aggressive and now I think that Fabiana
can play f3 kind of solidify his his
defensive situation support efore and
and then get back to work on the
queenside so I I like his approach here
I'm guessing his moves which means
there's something wrong but no it looks
like white is in control on na and I
think that I think that you phone's
gonna be in trouble here unfortunate
game indeed I think too much could
really get hurt at going in this game
and as you can see from the game 3 that
he won when she gets a going she gets a
coin really good buys yes something went
wrong into the opening at this one and
yeah finally rook c7 comes in the b7
pawns gonna fall in I think okay maybe
we'll see Brooke f7 here by Yvonne just
so she can bring the other rook to f8
and kind of really be all in yeah she
she she agrees this is her last chance
but I doubt it's gonna be enough I mean
okay if you play rook f7 rook takes b7
you double rooks on the F file maybe at
some point here black's looking to
capture on e4 and and busts things open
but you feel like it's just too much and
Fabiano takes on f5 early just to kind
of say yeah that's not gonna happen
I'm not gonna let that happen definitely
so always some practicals can't ago when
both players only have a minute left on
the clock yes I saw yesterday with net
Bowen LaVon there were all sorts of
twists and turns and sorts of blunders
of the time pressure
so I keep on deciding now between a
capture back on on f7 both have their
definition C's King takes f7 yes but it
looks like there's a fork coming on on
chief or so I mean she doesn't want to
take with the king but she might have to
because if Queen takes is there just a
move like g4 it looks like it might be
coming yeah pretty strong Danny I don't
know what to do he goes for it you just
have to each one each one and as one of
my teammates just said in the chat Fork
town well 92 even stronger it's yes even
stronger and I think I think you phone's
gonna probably try her hand in the next
game because this looks like it's
now out of chances okay maybe she plays
Bishop takes chief or here and gets a
couple pawns and plays a few more moves
but I think it's over if the Bishop g4
was played takes Queen takes then there
was just Queen f3 anyway so yeah alright
well you know it's tough yeah I don't
exactly know what I'm you know not not
strong enough to know exactly where I
went wrong for back but from the
beginning you could feel it was slightly
it was a slightly awkward version of
some positions we might see otherwise
like an Enzo and then you get this pawn
chain for a King side attack but felt
like blacks position never quite caught
up and and eventually just got crushed
because of this early c5 idea that
Fabiano played I really think that was
kind of a key strong move when he played
move c5 on move 12 and all of a sudden
black was just on her heels yeah it was
really definitely not one of the closer
games that we saw on this match Dani
disagreed like I think the first if you
watch the first four games at this match
and you can say like you know she
definitely has a chance you know she's
been playing some good moves and five
he's just playing above the rim but I
wouldn't say that about this last game
yeah that's agreed not not the best one
so far but she gets white again in the
next one Fabiana we'll we'll be back to
work with the black pieces assuming that
he takes care of business here I think
it's just a matter of a few seconds and
okay made that move with point two
seconds on the clock as we could see she
got 2.2 all right the game is still
going on you're right yeah yeah we've
never not a decisive chess over the last
48 hours Jen yesterday we only had six
draws in in the 27 games played total
between the palm naxi and Levon Aronian
I don't know if that was a record Mike
Mike client will check on that for us
mister stab boy but I think only six
rolls in 27 games was about as a big
decisive percentage as we've ever had
and this I mean today we've had no draws
so far at all
this is about to be our fifth decisive
game as soon as Fabiano takes care of
takes care of business here so yeah
we've had no draws so far decisive chess
being played which is always fun for the
fans and we'll see if you Vaughn can can
strike back here now that she gets
the first move Fabiano rotating his
position a lot he fun is not quite not
quite pentola Hari Krishna level on if
you remember last year's event Jen but
Patel Hari Krishna was so still on
camera it almost felt like he was a
statue like he didn't blink for an hour
and a half it was insane and and today
Fabiano's moving around a lot to the
point where we can't ever quite see him
clearly on camera but you've gone I mean
has she raised as she lowered her her
left hand on her cheek the entire day
there might be yeah that happens though
the so this started out is is a console
and I we're headed into a hedgehog type
structure for black and yeah I got it or
they go more like it looks like some
kind of rack seemed fine ish position
where the night it's on s parades it on
before so that for very early
Bishop f4 by holy fun but 95 is usually
a good response to that move because you
don't really want to take on 85 and just
let because the thing that white has
going for him her in this position is
she's got more space right no trades
really benefit blacks superb structure
what one of the ideas of this I mean
there's there's some lines in the
console Cillian where the bishop is here
you play something like h3 to make sure
that Bishop doesn't go anywhere on that
diagonal and then you slowly work toward
kind of building up the pressure on the
e5 Knight so it can't stay there
things like h3 b3 to guard c4 you double
bricks on the D file and eventually
maybe even try to relocate the night
from f3 to play f4 so okay it's kind of
a slow plan in the maroc c buying but
this d6 pawn is weaker here than it
would normally be in like a hedgehog
maroc c buying right because that Bishop
is on g7 instead of a 17 it so I've seen
ideas like this with the mission 104 but
you're right it is it is awkward for
white here because black has sort of
firmly put that knight on e5 and it's
not going anywhere
yeah and you can't really you can't
really easily put any other pressure on
you six I mean that that's why it's so
difficult to play against the structure
and blitz even though you know you feel
like oh I could be a little better it
feels like you're hitting your head
against a wall sometimes Bishop III was
holy pawns choice attacking the pawn on
d6 quick rook e8 by Fabia now after
Knight takes not on e5
interesting choice here for Fabi you
could even consider taking over I think
that is much better yeah I think that
yeah surprising maybe initially because
some of our beginner chess players
voluntarily taking on the double pawns
but a really instructive idea to show
that when you have double pawns in the
center they often control some of the
most critical squares so that's kind of
the key point and when they're not on an
open file they're not really targets
either right it's not like these are
isolated double fawns on an open file so
a really nice move I think to take with
the D pawn eliminating the d6 weakness
and now this pony's gonna hop into d4
and I'm already starting to like blacks
position again yeah I love it here
because you can when you're black here
you don't have a lot of space and you
can certain breathing a sigh of relief
if you have this pawn on e5 because you
know that you're just gonna own the d4
square and we may have to check waited
Eric Aviano for some kind of stimulants
after the matches he just put something
in his mouth looked like some Advil he's
got a headache no I'm kidding he's got a
headache but he just he just opened some
sort of pill bottle and put in his mouth
I'm sure that Anton's squared me on
Twitter is already making a gif about
that one oh yeah I bet I still wanted to
make any more gifts about me last yeah
he goes he goes to town he made a gift
yesterday about me because I wasn't
currently following him on Twitter and
he went a little over the top with the
drama I'm not gonna lie he can be he can
be a bit a bit a bit over the time I did
see that one Godfather yeah The
Godfather you know they did do a study I
saw it on PJ's website that um better
the only stimulants that were shown to
improve chest performance for like
coffee and like something like adderall
but it was liked by a very small mouth
so kind of what you would expect like
right for Chasse right
alright well the transition in the sin
has opened things up we've got still
equal pawns but a whole bunch of weird
pawns this is something we learned right
in Hans comic you know pawn pawn power
and chess you've got a bunch of pawn
islands
you've got doubled weak pawns for white
on the Queen side you've got this
isolated b6 pawn and double pawns for
black on the e-file so a strange
structure but one more I think we kind
of like black just because the bishop
pair for black means that as the
position becomes more open likely black
has the better set of minor pieces and
also the bee pollen seemed to be a
little weaker do you agree I think
blacks a little better here I don't know
I mean it's hard to assess this position
because it's the structure so weird but
yeah this movement
Fabiano played so confidently Queen
before it does look pretty good and we
finally see Fabiano's face on camera
it's a celebration that that we can see
both players for the moment and I don't
have a good way to defend me three
because well I was thinking after work
c3 before well the thing important I'm
giving away all these key squares yes
yeah after Bishop d4 it seems that my
pieces have suddenly improved a time so
he starts with that four and maybe now
he for that you push the uh you've
pushed the bishop back yeah I agree but
f4 seems like a weird decision and maybe
not as counter positional as I first
think cuz it's not bughouse I can't just
pop a knight on e4 but I like this move
rook d3 by yifan I feel like if she can
relocate this Knight to e4 blocking the
the e5 pawn Fabiana might regret this
move f4 yeah but you probably didn't
like it for tactical reasons so now and
then you're right yet simply play Knight
c3 here yeah I have a hard time feeling
like black is still better here the
knight comes to c3 and here comes the
night into e4 and I feel like yeah here
and she's following that line I I don't
I don't really agree with Fogg and his
approach here and I'm starting to like
white's positional chances because if
that pawn on e5 gets stuck then that
Bishop on g7 is not nearly as good of a
piece as it is it could have been before
yeah I'm trying to figure out if we can
at some point if you can play some
comedy
efore and work the a somehow here if we
play work the immediately um what do you
do yeah well he goes for it we're gonna
find out because you're right now she
okay but it should be one is nice right
because that that ensures that at least
she's gonna stand a fighting chance to
hold the D file oh wow rook d4 that's a
nice move it you're inviting white to
take care everybody and that would undo
the e pawns and and improve black center
control and if you don't take on D for
the problem is now black owns the file
and will be able to double freely with
rook F to d8 so kind of an instructive
point there to see rook to d4 I wonder
what she'll do
maybe ninety four and you also can't
clean ninety four because we can capture
it I wonder if there's some ideas Jen of
something like nine a four gain a tempo
on the Queen and once it moves maybe
then Bishop c3 and kind of force the
issue okay she plays nine a4 we'll see
if I'll but Queen d6 prevents my bishops
III idea exactly so you maybe you got a
trade on d4 even though you don't want
to and then or you can play Queen or
something as well should go through that
but here comes here comes rook FD 8
right and then she's gonna she's gonna
be forced to trade likely anyway yeah
the question will will be reenter in but
I still think White's okay here and
she's up a little bit on time I mean if
we look at analysis like rook d4 or
sorry rook FDA rook takes d4 takes maybe
the though the bishop comes to f2 where
it hits d4 and behind it b6 oh wow he
plays rook d2 I like that even better
just may just kind of you know playing
chicken here she's not gonna blink first
and she's gonna try to stare down black
on the D file yes your changes that come
after were tasty for so she plays this
just retreating move which would escape
the vision of a lot of people but it
makes sense that's where her bishop is
and she's got enough control they're
still you guys think
your hobby what about trying to get the
movie Eastbourne yeah I was gonna say
dynamically maybe you got to go in and
go all-in on e4 and if you don't play
you for gem then probably that night on
a four comes back to c3 and and maybe
you lose your chance so I wouldn't be
surprised that that's what he's thinking
about despite being under a minute maybe
he kind of senses a critical moment and
needs to find something here yeah but
the thing about efore is which way are
you gonna take back if I capture me for
what's your plan I hadn't gotten that
far you know people are just Queeny for
yeah it just makes with the Queen you're
right so so Fabiano gets the Queen off
of that file maybe because of that so
he's gonna yeah now after Bishop f2 we
see a quick train this is getting better
and better for Yifan I mean not only on
the clock but look at how she's
outplayed him here I mean really she has
cuz that d-file pressure was real and
she defended off the the Lions there and
she's gonna pick up the b6 pawn and be
better in this endgame but there's still
tactics video a let's see should be five
here he's banking on the fact that the
two bishops are gonna provide some
counter chances yeah how much way are
you gonna take on one b6 you're gonna
take with a knife I I was originally
thinking that but now I'm looking at it
maybe I can't take with the bishop but I
think taking with the night makes the
most sense Jen because maybe then
there's threats like Queen d7 and I can
try to start simplifying the position so
I kind of like Knight takes certainly
you're right I mean if black is able to
gobble the e4 pawn maybe bring the Queen
to g5 I mean there are things to worry
about here as the bishop pair get active
in the center but I feel like some
accurate moves and she does have more
time so she's I'm confident whatever the
best approach is here she's gonna find
it because you know again that's we
always talk about time and it's clear to
see time when it's a problem but when
you have more time in the critical
moment it should you know stand a reason
you'll likely be able to find the best
moves and I think she'll she's probably
calculating these variations now so she
goes for Knight takes my face b6 is
definitely more natural I like that
tempting to play there should be six
threatening the liquidating Queenie
but this move looks really more in
keeping with the feeling of the position
so queen g4 check she's the first one to
invade and Bobbi's King now yeah I think
he's got a go king of seven even though
he doesn't want to cuz if King h8 all
this take e6 and you don't have time to
take G - because I'm threatening Queen
takes e5 ok yeah they're going for it
but I really like you fawns chances now
I think she's gonna get this one the
night um p6 can also come in to d5 gen
and maybe white launches a mating attack
95 here Bishop Bishop can't take g2
anymore and then the Knights threatening
to come to e7 so I think if she finds 95
its she's she's uh she's in in good
shape yes and she's also still got that
huge lead on the clock so she can also
just play clean eh Shaq and Queen d7 if
you want yeah this was also interesting
look at that double attack of Bishop d4
check simplifying and Queen f8 mate
everybody yeah now she'll play Bishop d4
check and just eliminate I think she'll
just eliminate blacks chances like
getting rid of that dark square Bishop
unless she has something better I mean
she's she's looking okay she decides she
has something better yeah this looks
very I mean black King is just so
horribly exposed right yep
maybe Queen g5 no she continues for the
attack here
you know she's assuming she gets this
one with the accurate move she's played
it really feels like he's made extra
time well Jen like when she's had an
advantage you know she used her time in
those positions to really convert
accurately we in the two victories she
has gotten in this match again assuming
she goes on to get this one I feel like
she's managed her time well in those
critical moments yeah it's definitely an
impressive game indeed because it looked
like Fabiano's pressure on the defiled
they look did look a very scary
Wiki to idea out which assignment it and
it seems so passive on the surface but
actually it was just a good move that
was hardly working pressure against yeah
now she's putting on some technique for
the fans right showing them how to win a
bishop ending like this slowly taking
your time making this past pawn here now
she's gonna run over here and get yet
another pawn under fire that's called
the principle of two weaknesses
everybody established an advantage on
one side of the board oh did she just
blunder into six long though whoa that
could have been a huge blunder there
with Kingdom before look at the trick
Fabiano late mm-hmm Wow super tricky but
there is this little save here that oh
but there's just be seven probably still
winning actually okay I think I really
fast there yeah but I I think she's
actually still winning luckily but yeah
the King before and King be five I
wonder how early Fabiano saw that shot
because that was a super little tricky
defensive resource there now she's gonna
come into b7 so that's why your father
you plead a five himself and she's gonna
be able to pick up this pawn with tempo
Bishop c3 she'll take it with tempo and
then after the bishop moves she should
be able to play moves like Bishop d8 and
guard the f6 square preventing the King
from getting it so I think Fabiano is
still lost here okay so if I'm gonna
seize that idea coming he knows that if
now if takes he can play Bishop e5 and
Bishop d8 shouldn't work okay but but
she has this move King c4 and then if
king of six Bishop c3 forces the trade
yes she found it there it is yep I think
I think I think this one's finally in
the books once she gets Bishop c3 yeah
okay
impressive Jen Wow really great play
there by you fawn and she she strikes
there with only ten minutes left here in
the five-minute portion we have a match
everybody that was you know when she's
won she has really outplayed thing
finally on from start to finish as you
said the situation on the D file was
tricky but but she made her way through
that that complicated middle game to win
to win the endgame and the thing
most about the way she's playing is that
even when she loses a really bad game
she just comes back fire and exam is if
nothing happened yes not gonna she's not
gonna rattle door tilt it as we say in
poker
so that really bodes well for the rest
of this matches we saw yesterday the key
is keep it within two points so they
don't mean it's that bullet section
there anything yep I think I lost the
bet Jen I had a bet it wouldn't take
more than 60 minutes for you to get a
first poker reference in but it was
nearly 90 minutes before you referenced
poker so I owe I owe Matt five bucks for
that one so great for those who don't
know or don't follow Jen Shehadeh on
Twitter she's also a mean you consider
yourself still kind of a semi
professional poker player or not as much
anymore
yeah there's lovely yes I have a baby
now but luckily there's a lot of poker
in my area and I am still the mine
sports ambassador for Poker Stars so
yeah it's it's great
gotta love both games a little bit in
this game what do we got here it looks
like we've got a typical situation where
we've got an English and Hawaii the
position is actually pretty symmetrical
and White's got an extra tempo so will
he be able to get anything out of it
yeah I mean it's a it's a symmetrical
structure but you kind of like whites
position with the bishop on g2 maybe
there's tactics there but I don't I
don't see I don't see anything concrete
at this time sometimes what's deceptive
about these positions is it looks like
it's just gonna be equal because there's
no pawn you know weaknesses for either
side it's a structural very simple
position but suddenly everything gets
traded and white ends up owning the D
file and and you know Brooke comes to d7
and you're losing in the endgame I've
lost I've lost some games like that so
black has to be careful that everything
doesn't just get traded and and white
ends up controlling these D and C files
apparently your main game these days is
Chinese open-faced poker is that true I
yeah I played a lot of open-faced
Chinese poker the last few years okay
pure so I'm kind of going back to the
classic know them and hold them in some
other mix and you're also I think the
first person ever to do a similar thing
bullet or blitz just while playing PO
for those of you haven't seen that video
Jen played on chess calm and played
poker at the same time so that was funny
but alright enough poker references
Knight to d2 is played Fabiano is gonna
try to support that position on e5 with
either Knight to c4 or Knight f3 but
your phone should be okay here I think
the black can usually deal with these
tactics in a safe way although although
after take c5 I guess the worry is you
can't just play Bishop d6 genna's
because there would be some trades and
then something like 94 but if you can be
7 your queen is hanging so you have to
take back 183
there's no way Fabiano saw that move
coming gem we got to show that on the
analysis board cuz that that looks like
a really strong tactic free fun in fact
so much so that he's gonna sack the
Queen oh my gosh yeah show everybody
what would happen there cuz the tacker
so fast if taken here what Jim was
saying is after check black is able to
get rid of this bishop with check before
then regaining the knight and black just
used that whole combination to go into
an endgame up a career pawn so knight 93
was a really really nice combination and
a shot that I'm sure if I'll be on a
missed now this force is kind of counter
sacrifice here from 5e where he's got
what a working a piece for well he's not
doesn't have the work yet but he's gonna
win that work on a a right yep so he's
gonna end up with a work and a piece for
the Queen which shouldn't be enough but
it'll be interesting one of the things
that mic'd mentioned in his preview
article is Fabiana was willingness to
sack the queen in kind of a tough
position he seems to be sort of sort of
loose with that idea in the sense that
okay if he misses something he's not
afraid to go for an imbalance and play
with the pieces versus the Queen and
Mike Mike had some really interesting
examples of that I had to mention it one
cuz Mike's preview article was good and
two because that's our first Queen sack
of the match yeah I love the article by
Mike and you know it's funny that you
mention it because I just had so much
fun playing over that game of - verse
Borya
Eider where she knows a lot Queen yeah
it was funny how he showed kind
the synchronicity of that and heroin is
famous victory it's Nakamura with the
Queen sak and now we've got a queen
sacked in their game our first nun
although according to of my staff member
who has the engine running off lining
just gives me periodic updates he says
according to the analysis they the
engines comfortably comfortably like
black hair to be able to have an edge
with the Queen but but okay I'm looking
tonight is a rook in a night and it
takes some technique if you can
coordinate the two pieces properly it's
not easy for the Queen to get going
normally what you want here everybody if
you have the Queen is to find a way to
get her in the center on open lines as
quickly as possible the sooner she gets
in squares like this where she can poke
at things on both sides of the board the
sooner the Queen can kind of flex her
muscles and outplay the rook in the
minor piece yeah the two games at
reference in our preview article are
actually like two minor pieces first
Queen so obviously but they were also
more brilliant and inspired in this case
Fabiano carolina felt compelled the
sacrifice Queen you didn't really go
into it intentionally think he was gonna
be better yep nice move by holy fun she
knows in an order to win with the Queen
what's good about the Queen yep no lines
against the way King great point and
that's exactly along the lines of what
we were saying the moment you get
weaknesses on both sides of the board is
the moment the pieces just struggle so
much to stay on the board with the Queen
because because she's so powerful
sliding back and forth a check here upon
weakness over there and so h5 was a
really strong move and she's going to
continue to try to poke weaknesses open
and and so the Queen can kind of
dominate on the diagonals and the file's
this looks like this looks like she's on
pace to to bring the match within a game
jenn and we only have three and a half
minutes remaining in the first portion
so i'm pretty sure if you had asked her
starting if she would have taken a one
game deficit heading into the first
chess960 battle she would have said sign
me up because this is this is proving to
be a close match I think it might be a
little bit hard to to call it right now
though it still requires some technique
but I like what she's doing now she's
clean her clean in position but
on her mind fi fi sorry I misspoke she's
got to find the right moment to play the
move g5 to continue opening up the
position instead actually she's probably
a better idea she wants to play e5 f5
and then at four right I've also been
surprised that she didn't she could have
also played rook c2 last move I guess at
some point we'll see that I'm I was a
little surprised she didn't just try to
get another set of rooks off the board
but maybe I'm wrong about that maybe she
has better winning chances if she can
open up the King while she still has
that rook on the board to maybe help
with an attack yeah I think so I think
that I think I like keeping instead of
works on the board you think of it
white's rooks are potentially
superfluous whereas we have like one
rook that we can use an attack g3 and
stuff right so yeah good point and maybe
now that rook can get into c3 and
suddenly ideas like Queen f5 and a date
on the h3 Square has white and big
trouble yeah exactly like for instance
if we play work c3 and you play rook d3
we might have just to move Queen e2
advantage of the fact that work c3
allows Queen B 1 so yeah this is looking
like some pretty good technique by holy
fun working for it looks pretty terrible
because we can just take on e2 right
yeah you may have to go for that though
if rook d4 Queen e2 you would love to be
able to take out for with the rook to
guard f2 but of course that's not
possible and so that's the problem that
you if you take with the bishop to hangs
if you take with the rope do you want
hands so you can't actually play rook
thief I guess I was thinking he might
have rook d4 Queen e2 and then rook one
to d2 in her mizo and then you know if I
move like Queen g4 has played now you
can take with the rook so that the
bishop remains guarding the H pawn so I
agree with you I mean it looks it looks
sketchy but I'm wondering if there's any
better option then than to try to go
rook d4 Queenie to rook one to d2 and
then because I don't think I don't think
you fun can avoid the F for fall and
fall falling after that I don't know I
can maybe put can i play like Queen e1
and it works you on maybe I think you
Queenie one Bishop takes rook see what
yeah you're right ok there's definitely
an attack there so she's
so he's just played kingi one okay so
he's just trying to defend passively
here thinking that the active active
idea would have just lost and now how
does this work she three move it we were
looking at earlier activating Naraku uh
yeah I don't know but if the brook gets
to h3 then it looks too good to be true
right if she plays rook to c3 rookie ch3
then the mating attack is on so I'm sure
she's calculating that idea along with
ideas like f3
because if you can punch okay Wow now
she's gonna simplify which I guess that
makes sense right she avoided
simplification now that she got kind of
the transition she wanted where that G
file is open there's gonna be problems
for the king
Brooksie to look stuff because if you
trade queen take C two wins a pawn just
immediately there's no way white can
guard everything exactly that's a
problem doesn't really look playable so
you kind of have to like maintain the
tension there I think and then maybe the
move three is gonna be really beastly
because after like if we came to play f3
and you take we can just play Queen f3
leave their work hanging on c2 because
you can't take it Queen d1 wins two for
the price of one so this works each who
seems to come at the right moment and he
felt compelled to take it anyway but
that quantity to is is going down yeah
and I think once it does that's when you
really see the Queen get going okay
there's threats of Bishop f6 that's what
you got to be worried about if somehow
Queen e2 Bishop f6 can come back for
them yeah okay there you go yeah and
just wins on the spot so yeah I seem
like he's got a yeah no no we need to
just look devastating because if you
take on a second I can't imagine you
know Queenie to work a7 f3 looks just
like too dangerous we're threatening um
you're not gonna be able to stop meeting
ideas and the lights where yeah the
lights we're being
- yeah well it looks like that's likely
to happen and we've officially reached
the end of the five - portion the
chess960 game will be starting
immediately after this and and we will
see how these two players fare when when
the pieces are not where they're used to
being and that should be fun can't wait
to see what we have in store there all
right well she's checking back and forth
here I think it makes sense for the
Queen to be on e4 have ideas like queen
bee one queen chief or Queenie one just
kind of owning the whole board in the
center now here comes your idea of three
I think and it's almost over here
yeah just go gobble the H pawn makes
sense the queen guards d4 so there's no
Bishop d4 trying to line up to hit g7
yeah really the huge threat there and
here it is just 960 um ok Knights are
worse than normal in this position Danny
I'm gonna say I like the bishops here
yeah absolutely it's uh normally these
are my these are my least favorite
chess960 positions Jen where the where
the Knights are in the corner
I just hate those because I just I play
I play like a brand of chess where I get
going a little too crazy in the center
and then before I know it I never
develop my night off of a1 or h1 so but
ok you fun says I'm not gonna play like
that immediately getting the knight out
of the edge and then Fabiano follow suit
we have a symmetrical structure so far
yeah it's kind of interesting what you
say about the Knights because it goes to
show you that in the position that we
actually start out with in chess Knights
are a lot stronger than they would be if
they're they're starting in the corner
and yeah you see that both players are
trying to address that immediately by
developing them quickly very very
principled chess here by both of these
players and Anna and I were on the edge
of our seat the last game about when
somebody would Castle and you see a big
flip-flop of a king and rook in the
center and suddenly the whole dynamic of
the position changes but we'll see if
that happens here you Fon gets a check
yeah but if he's right if she trades off
that dark square Bishop I'm worried
about the III and and D two squares so
we'll see how she deals with
that III hole seems like she's gonna
castle now oh okay oh did she just Mouse
live she meant I think she thought king
c1 was gonna castle
yeah that's what I she meant to I think
she meant to Castle and she she messed
that up she did do it correctly and now
she's got problems well what happened is
she just moved king c1 but you have to
do is put the king on top of the Brooke
otherwise it thinks you're making a move
king c1 yeah that's unfortunate because
usually it takes practice Chang playing
chess 960 online which we do recommend
and are in our pre match emails with the
players to make sure they know that
because because we've seen it happen
before but yeah it in right yeah you
could type it in you can also drag it
the easiest thing is to drag the king to
like a1 like if you put the king kind of
like but over the rook you kind of flip
flop it the you know it the easiest
thing to avoid any sort of slippage of
the mouse yeah a lot of people in the
chatter saying that we should message
her before the next 960 but she knows
how to do it we will I will hire in the
chat I was lucky enough to call it his
match against Sergei car yakking with
you earlier this year that was a great
match wow that was a great match it was
a lot of fun and we saw we saw cardiac
inand Meyer play a similar brand of
chess in karyakin just play it a little
bit of a higher level there but it was
it was a very strategical match and
really instructive match actually all
right well you fought is making the best
of the situation here though Jen right I
mean she's got the apon advanced here I
think that with the Queen on c5 and the
King on c1 this is it's almost like
she's castled long right the King on c1
and the rook on e1 look okay and I don't
think this is this is as bad as it as it
could have been given that we're all
pretty sure king c1 was a mouse slip and
not something she meant to do yeah and
now there's some pressure on the I still
gotta like black here there's some
pressure on the pawn on d5 though
interesting and there's always some like
sacrificial ideas here for black as well
but you know there's a lot of material
getting traded as well
yeah I wonder you know we talked about
you Fonz inexperienced in 1960 online
Caruana also probably has more
experience over the board I mean he's
played in these these ultimate blitz
things right against Nakamura and st.
Louis the the chess960 showdown and so
Carmen actually scored what was it that
he win that match two and a half one and
a half or he lost one and a half two and
a half he won the showdown in st. Louis
but I don't even exact 960 score yeah I
think we actually lasted just 960 games
but or went one to have two and a half
but and that's a surprise to me because
you always think of Nakamura as me
American boots guy and is the number one
readed but obviously bobby has mad
skills as well actually when he gets on
a roll
yep well remind everybody right after
this chest night whoa rook takes e to
forget the reminder was that what what
happened did he just lies Mao slipped at
ya okay rematch we got to abort this
game let the players know they're not
making it very easy to get a hold of
them on on our group chat I don't know I
don't know what happened
yeah the I think he I think he mouse
slipped or he just forgot that the night
was on E - because I'm not sure how you
how you do that oh the game was aborted
that I mean they're gonna have a brand
new 960 or me no no we're we're ready
for a break time okay but wait okay all
right of course yeah okay so we're gonna
have a little break here yep break in
the action and both players will
actually get up from their from their
chairs and maybe maybe take a quick
break here we are letting them know okay
and and that's what they're gonna do and
I got a take a moment here Jenn to say
first of all this has been a super
exciting match let's remind everybody
that with that big win
Yifan has just tied things up and it is
a four-four game heading to the three
minute portion but I also need to give
our first official official shoutouts to
the sponsors reminder that the 2017
speech Chess Championship is brought to
you by
after class everybody's excited for
Garry Kasparov scores do you know much
about this course Jen have you seen a
preview of the course oh yeah I've seen
some previews of any made it looks
fantastic and I know you guys were
involved with that right well we we had
some team members there on site kind of
helping both Mike Klein and Matt Lodge
two of our guys that were able to get
there and kind of help with the filming
but the big thing is they have
contributed to help bring the speeches
championship here and we have a quick
word of a reminder for probably the rare
few fans out there who haven't seen this
promo yet let's let's take a look and
listen in here to the Garry Kasparov
commercial and remind you to pre-order
the master class from Garry Kasparov and
and eagerly await the release of that I
think it's coming at the end of this
month at the beginning of September so
here we go let's take a listen in check
[Music]
but it's not just check span attacks you
have to be creative
let's come with king g5 king c2 king of
six couldn't be speaking g17c 14 to 16
before Kings a certain cases boom
white lost yes twin takes the knight f5
and it's double attack so let's go back
and see what's the next logical groups
obscure and attraction
- mate what an amazing mate I've been
thinking about few ideas that I never
used what I want to show that's one of
my favorite Oh breaks it's not about
winning or losing but of course at the
end of the day it's about whatever I'm
Gary Kasparov and this is my master
and we're back and a nice little
commercial there from Gary at the end of
the day it's about winning or losing at
the end of the day someone is gonna win
or lose this match but we are no closer
to knowing that at this point because we
have got a deadlock gen4 for a mate you
know again a little disappointing
therefore Fabiano if we if we see what
happened in that game reminder to
everybody if you if you're just joining
us the the last game here with with rook
takes e to still just don't quite know
what happened there maybe he was
intending rookie three and he just mouse
slipped and that happens sometimes right
yeah the rook coming to e3 probably
would have been pretty effective though
right so unfortunate there for car water
ironic because of course there was a
also announced lit by oh you find in the
same game but hers was inning and
Bobby's right slightly more devastating
agreed and it looks like we are we are
off and Fabiano has has played his first
move Yifan is still not quite back yet
in her chair so hopefully she's back
shortly
Ian who do you like in the even faster
game I honestly do not know I I like to
think that I tend to like the stronger
players as the time controls get faster
and I'm not sure that you Fon knows that
her game has started just yet no there
is 30 seconds now she knows the game has
started and she's made her move and and
we are off you know what I tend to feel
you know just from doing a lot of these
matches that even though even when you
think someone's not a bullet specialist
or not as fast as the other person I
mean even yesterday Levon Aronian who's
not supposed to be as good at bullet I
feel like as the time Twitchell's got
faster he he still played a higher
quality brand of chess in the end he
made a few more steaks under under time
pressure you know that was kind of my
perspective there and didn't quite hold
up and and I think he was a little
frustrated at times but but overall I
tend to feel
the faster the time control the more I
believe the stronger player does well
with some exceptions some players that
are just exceptional you know maybe with
mouth speed or something but I'll be
curious to see how you fawn holds up as
things speed up here we have my favorite
opening the Sicilian I kind of like it
for both sides so I don't really know
who to pick here both of us both of us
here I agree I don't know who to pick us
as having the the I know that I like to
play both positions here Bishop d7 comes
in and now you got to deal with the
knight on a4 or often in this line you
can actually play be free believe it or
not everybody yeah and Fabiano does it
and the reason is that this trade okay
you phone's going to do it but this is
not as bad of a position as you may be
first meets the eye for white because
white has gained the bishop pair if
you're not careful as as black sometimes
white is able to get a lot of control
over the light squares because white has
the bishop the black doesn't so but
that's said I'm not sure that move oh
I'm sitting here saying that because I
know this is an idea and I'm thinking I
wonder if that move order was was really
the best for white I kind of forget
maybe you remember your English attack
theory a little better than me right now
but but I want to say this is this is
okay for white just might now ugly that
looks usually the Sicilian end games are
pretty good for black but in this case
it sobbing I know judges that the games
gonna be good for him after Queen d3
look rookie three or Pondy three well
it's he's not gonna find out because
holy fun said no no Queen trade but now
after don't we have this move g6 so it
looks pretty powerful eight you have 95
Intermezzo yeah I agree and lucky for
you fawn the the time is getting close
to equal despite her sort of 30-second
you know spotting her opponent about 30
seconds but the moment you get g6 the
moment you get g6 we start to love white
in these positions don't we I mean g6 is
just so nice to undermine the e6 pawn
and normally I like white here we do it
away but there's also this problem of 95
right I mean that's giving you more
counter
plain normal because the pond on a fort
is hanging but you find chose to play 95
instead that's also very powerful if he
moved but maybe 3 is gonna be met by 94
yep so she's holding on
Fabiano is I mean he fought is certainly
you know a good Sicilian player herself
but I think Fabiano has established
himself as one of the world's elite in
terms of playing the white side of these
positions he's one of the few men brave
enough to take on MVL in the night off
right yeah and I mean we've seen that
happen in st. Louis and other times
where Fabiano you know most people just
avoid the night or four against against
the Frenchmen for those who follow top
chefs know that but Fabiano's not afraid
of the English attack so I guess I tend
to always think that he knows what he's
doing here and I still like white I like
a 5 coming here possibility friending
rook takes g7 check in 96 I like that
idea yeah what is interesting so is that
5 the one thing about this position in
general the black moves come a little
bit more obvious right you know that's
one of the things about having a good
position and he's chosen night at none
of the movie book that had javi the 5
that's that's interesting right he's
just saying everybody's saying well if
you're just gonna take the pawn all
you're doing is giving me more lines to
get at your King and okay you fawns
going for it she's gonna call his bluff
and go after the pawns and uh and go
after the bishop money frame and go
after the fish money free well I mean
one of the big things we have to mention
here I mean it's obvious if for those
who've been following the match of
course and you see the score so you know
it obviously it is tied but this could
be Yvonne's first chance since the
beginning of the match to take the lead
right Jenn I mean she fell behind
she caught back up and if she won this
game the underdog is is out front okay
so just for Kiki one and I was gonna say
that um you know he's got there wasn't
really a clear discovery because Bishop
moving could have been met by a what
anyway one now there is yeah I wonder
did she have did she have night a three
in the last position just kind of
breaking through and and you know one of
the things about 93
last move yet as if the King comes to be
to rook takes situ wins because the
night is now pinned to the king so I
wonder if she just knows that wild but
is it just good for right yeah this is
the kind of chess we want to see this is
this is awesome here I mean even Knight
a3 is still in the air at any moment for
black and white has to be super careful
there maybe even rook b8 first should be
played but but with the Queen hanging
with the Queen hanging sheet something's
gone wrong here for her I mean now okay
thank it was was play it's like she's
just gonna take on b3 and then take on
a3 and try to bail out that way Danny
you know it's not losing material wealth
and the endgame is is not as bad I guess
for black his first seems is she's kind
of down a pawn but the h4 pawn is
hanging the 18 chapters in the air to
check is in the air because of the c2
pawn under fire I feel like we're gonna
see c4 and maybe Fabiana goes all-in
giving her the H pawn but but even that
still looks like it could be anybody's
game here and once it was what's the
difference between three minutes gen we
are already under serious time pressure
look at that right both sides about 40
seconds and and the clock is ticking but
working seven checks staying active
that's something that you'll often see
from really strong players even in blitz
games in the NBA and they notice they
active in their balls right like it's a
that's the difference and this looks
really effective you agree here comes
the attack and I'm still so curious
about that previous 93 move I think I
think you found mr. win and maybe a
chance like we said to get a lead in the
match but but okay it's a night off and
not much time on the clock pretty hard
to judge the players for not seeing
every little tactic
alright well but now we're getting a
position where you really feel like
whites the only one who can win this
rook ending that King at age five
we were like trying to trying to come
back into the game with the idea that
our Bishop was a stronger piece by now
enjoy your game it's obviously a lot
harder because once Bobby please c4 and
start
ganging up on the a3 pond he's going to
go up to ponds
and you can never take on an h4 with a
king because there's just a check me so
that's why you see you find going after
the pawn with the rough and this is
probably a good way to try to get
counter play because there was something
crazy going on on move 33 though on move
33 I think that Knight f4 was was was
was made to follow after King takes h4
there's ideas like rook to d3 heading
rotate h3 with Jack so another maybe a
few in hindsight this may be a game
where both sides miss wins and who knows
maybe the poetic justice will see a draw
no okay Bobby ah no trades no perpetual
and I and I think he should still be
winning in this rook ending despite
missing the other end game that we saw
him win where he's going to end up
having to write yep very similar to that
game and that's and we're gonna see a
similar result with Caruana winning here
and in fact ufone agrees and throws in
the towel so Wow
quite the back and forth affair both
sides seemingly missing wins but we had
a sharp night or so we got all we could
ask for yeah really we've got another
French and so I was right Dani I
wouldn't that bet you were right you win
another bet
or you've lost me one bed and now you
get now you win another one so the
French is back a different line this
time not a tirage playing a classical
French with D take c4
I haven't seen this line played at top
level Chesson and quite some time so
Fabi really keeping it mixed up and what
does he want to do with this King here
Dani that's what I'm always ask me my
students like for mr. king
okay so f5 is played okay he go he goes
for the knight c3 line other variations
with sometimes see the knight coming to
g3 but in this line okay white white can
Y can actually castle to both sides but
I think okay with that movie makes a
pretty clear intention he plans to
castle long and then the idea with the
rook on the D file is to either strike
with d5 or to look to open up the D file
some other way like Kingdom e1 here and
then maybe he's just gonna put the
knight on c5 and try to invite a trade
to open the rook
I would expect to see Knights e5 here
and yeah unless there's some other kind
of tactic but that's kind of the idea
here for white to aggressively open the
defiled but this is the move order with
f5 away sorry I'm thinking fun I'm
speaking as if he's white no she is why
she plays nice e5 I like that idea and
to answer your question about where
Fabiana puts the king usually the King
just sits tight in the center and this
would be five yeah maybe maybe she can
play Queen e5 here yes she goes for it I
think that that's okay because I think
that in the end game after Queen takes
and Knight takes if everybody just gets
traded white is just maybe not
dominating with the knight in the center
as it can be kicked with f6 but
currently the knight is certainly much
better placed than the black counterpart
so that's you know an early f6 could be
met by something like Knight takes c6
running c7 so that's why you gotta be a
little bit careful the softness of your
pawn on e6 coming into the game and now
this nice move g3 threatening Bishop g2
with a really monstrous Bishop
preventing you from developing your
knight on b8 yeah work on that unsavoury
a7 square so Bobby trying to release
some of the pressure with Bishop e5 but
you know and then Bishop c6 that's his
idea so that was that was pretty timely
otherwise he was gonna get really
crunched yeah
well now we're gonna see rook g1 and the
question is does he tried to play ninety
seven and trade or okay he has something
else in mind he wants to use the c6
square for the knight and that's why he
plays Bishop f3 with tempo if you give
black one more move he's gonna put the
knight on c6 and the e5 pawn is going to
come under fire so that's why g2 just in
the nick of time before black completely
consolidate yeah and I like white here a
lot I mean this is okay he played it he
played a French again and got kind of a
dynamic root position
but despite not taking advantage of the
king of the center maybe with an attack
you know she's owned the D file the
whole way here and and I think that as
soon as she solidifies that e5 pawn
maybe with a move like f4 she's just
better in this endgame I mean maybe you
play a four so that Knight to d7 could
even be met by Knight d7 and into d6
which I don't know that looks like it
could be fun put a knight on d6 that
Bishop on d5 is kind of irritating
though right I mean you fawn would love
to find a way to force that Bishop to
take g2 and reopen things for white on
the D file but Fabiano's not gonna do
that unless he has to because that
Bishop on d5 is holding the fort look at
that sac he didn't even want to take it
because of ideas like rook to d6 and and
the rook gets in and yeah in the
previous indeed but the problem is that
bishops going to be destabilized yeah
great panty yeah that was her whole idea
at some point c4 is gonna come what a
marvelous idea
probably it's trying to defend oh wow it
should really takes advantage of the pin
bishop now saying hey I don't even need
to guard g2 because you got tactical
problems of your own here with the TA
square coming see for the huge threat
Bobby felt it was necessary to play King
e7 and that knight on b8 is doing Oh
Bishop f1 trying to keep pieces on the
boards is so nice oh but that's gonna
blunder isn't to see oh no c4 doesn't
work as a bishop before I was just like
wait wait what's going on so black is
hanging on by a hair on his hint
chinny-chin-chin here barely so time out
we just play f3 or maybe King see you on
NC one looks good yeah I think King C
one gets the King off of it yeah and she
agrees with you and and now but but I
the rook can come to da right and the
work can come to the end although and
already it's it's hard to know where
maybe but it feels like white had more
pressure than she's been able to deliver
here especially with black
finding a way to coordinate on the B
file if course it feels that way because
we don't usually see or somebody is good
at defending is Fabiano Carolina that's
elite players are so good at defending
so you're like of course he's gonna go
down the pressure is enormous right we
move right we're talking about about the
caps for right yep yep they find they
find a lot more only moves than then
then I do for certainly than most people
do I mean it's just it's amazing to see
them defend those positions so
accurately and now Bishop d3 is our
strong move in her own right though
she's trying to guard the b1 square and
now she can play Brooke d2 as scary as
that looks she she might be able to
defend oh but she has c4 first stopping
the bishop from hitting a 2 and I bet
she plays rook d2 on the next move and
and she's kind of yeah and she's kind of
defended her way out of this just like
Fabiano did rook b to check is met by
King III and she gains a tempo just in
time that's right and of course that's
Bishop I mean she's good if she can
consolidate this position of course
she'll be better because she's got a lot
of structural advantages so find me
continuing to try to make it somewhat
tactical yuri plates nice move exit yes
really nice undermining the rooks
protection everybody now she's now she's
gonna have to play a position where yes
you have the a pawn but somehow Caruana
has gotten the central majority through
that little swindle with f6 I'm not sure
who's better here how do you evaluate
this I still feel like I like my EP if I
don't see how that that Center gets
moving and the King on e3 is doing a
really good job of keeping it from going
great forward right if you play e4 your
C - oh she goes to eat you I was gonna
say I don't like that because here comes
rook before I'm not sure that that was
the best for white I think Fabi should
play Brooke before here and go pick up
that C point although you might consider
he's played worked before and I think
this is good for black because when that
C pawn falls you and if White's somehow
picks up h7 are just gonna say she's
gonna go for this but this King is gonna
come up via f6 and and I feel like
blacks central majority is going to be
more dangerous than
white can muster and don't don't play
King III here oh she does it
I'm worried King e5 is some sort of
mating net is about to ensue for that
king but okay she's risking it one more
coin yep yep okay well Fabiano going
after the a pawn here comes the C pawn
it's gonna be H and a versus C and I
guess I'm agreeing with you now I feel
like this seems to be White's game to
win and and no longer one that she seems
to be in risk of losing I think probably
fine here plates for you're gonna play
h4 okay yes you check doesn't really
lead to anything you could even consider
playing King f4 on C to check and and go
all-in and I think Fabiano like that
idea so he prevents it with king e5 yeah
it's a work c5 check just offering the
chance for him to come back I don't know
what to play here King d4 a6 yeah she
goes with that one she's gonna force the
issue I think in trade and so again KF
45 would be trouble because yeah because
of the meeting instead she's just
transposed to this three verse 3 and
game where we've got these three center
Amano and she takes and undone doubles
the pawns but does so with the idea of
holding on the 5th rank and I guess
she's gonna just kind of say this is a
draw now
yeah cutting off the king that's
important otherwise black-white actually
be in huge trouble oh wait a second
white may be in a huge trouble
oh no no way she didn't see that but she
didn't know there at the end huh a shot
in the dark there to stay on the
analysis board and show everybody what
just happened after the check on a1
suddenly it was a miss
alkylation because the black is able to
sack everything because he's able to get
a queen and white could do nothing but
what she did she she played rook here
and gave a check but in the end there
was no way to stop queening so really
interesting and disappointing for white
because I think we felt like she was in
the driver's seat most the time there
and in the end just just made some
blunders under time pressure gen III
didn't see and prevent all that instead
of but indeed yay so you turned out to
be right
yeah any that the center pons created
more problems so you want that bad at
least yeah not really I think it took
took some mistakes by both sides to get
that but yeah it's it's crazy right
those it does say at least that that's
what happens in blitz we're like maybe
that's a game in a tournament that ends
up being played well by both sides
eventually Peters out to the appropriate
result of a draw right but in blitz you
know it's just super dynamic and tricky
and one side ends up blundering and
speaking of super dynamic and tricky
this takes me five allowing Bobby to
take on c6 and saying hey I mean after
takes on c6 on c6 Queen c6 Bishop d7 I
still got the two bishops you know and
I'm happy well dad Bobby's playing
Knight to f3 and you have to keep
checking this move Knight takes e5 right
because after 9525 you're Brooke is also
hanging on h8 but there's always a
Bishop g7 in it you know a big trade is
probably gonna occur with Bishop takes
d7 probably still just playable for both
sides but but maybe Caruana needs to go
gobble that pawn back despite the tempo
as it gives it gives black with Bishop
g7 on the Queen one one fun fun factoid
after that game even though it was close
to a draw and it did stay it did stay
decisive which means we have still yet
to have a single draw in this match and
and so far they're they're on pace to
beat the the speed Chess Championship
matched with the least amount of draws
ever was Carlsen versus Petrosian from
last year's first round only two draws
so anyway no draws
in this match we have had decisive games
every round I say we're gonna beat it no
drawers no drawers make your brother
proud no drawers no drawers and we do
have a six four score and yifan has not
won a game yet in the faster time
control Jen I don't know if it's really
because the time pressure just Fabiano
has played a couple of really
spectacular games would you agree yeah
extremely fast fan controls and very
tricky knows how to keep tricking even
if it looks like she is consolidated but
what about this position we've got a
situation where the prawn sacrifice but
this insane pressure on the D file so it
is seven pawns for black and six for
white but maybe five it's very dangerous
and good if you Castle let's see there I
think you have Knight takes east seven
maybe first you Knight can't take as d7
but maybe not actually I guess Queen
takes and everything seems fine so what
yeah but but I'm wholly fine decided to
play a six to start off yeah anyway
Bobby just put his Bishop back to c4 and
Syd didn't like that variation which
could have resulted in some kind of
Queen tie one of the issues here I think
for for black Jen is that even if let's
say she finds a way to get castled and
doesn't get punished horribly on the D
file it's all it's still going to be
super dynamic because you've got Kings
on opposite sides of the board and
Fabiano may find compensation and just
sort of rushing forward with an attack
like h4 and h5 yeah this is great I mean
this Bishop c4 move was class in Queens
yeah I was just gonna highlight that
exactly that the bishop finds itself on
a super nice diagonal to create those
tactics really good for four players to
learn to see the forest through the
trees there right look at the tactics
that may be not present but be aware of
those sort of things and you fawns aware
of it she plays Queen 85 and avoids
castles here Jen are we gonna see
castles long maybe she maybe she decides
to go the other side of the board yeah
this movie five is a nice fighting
um it feels like we should have
something here as white but King t97
King takes e7 not want to allow us to
like gobble I guess on b7 but now
there's always Bishop takes f7 mm-hmm I
think that Bishop takes f7 now just
looks like a clean steal of the pawn
because you can't really allow this idea
with the rook coming into d7 that would
just be too much yeah so I think
Fabiana wonder what he's calculating
here 3 bringing Queen to d7 and
community 6 check maybe he like that
better kind of keeping the pressure on
but no he's taking on f7 I was just
highlighting that Bishop f5 would be to
move but he goes for it and then plays
Queen to c4 which kills two birds with
one stone defends the Queen and the
bishop at the same time but but it's not
over here I mean yeah I was gonna say
rook c8 and you know this King is really
precarious but look at the situation
here right with with the rook bishop and
potentially Knight all lining up once
that Knight comes to b4 on this C 2
square and yeah no time for g4 g4 we may
be but you gonna play AC - yeah and no
time on the clock to figure it out Jen
he's got 22 seconds now he's got 24
seconds according to the engine here
actually white is already in big trouble
after he takes takes on the night before
and I again I only get those messages
from time to time Pete loves when he can
give me knowledge that I don't otherwise
see so according to Pete the engine
likes black a lot and it looks like Pete
was right because somehow the force
exchange here leads us to a position
where let's check on the players here
and what we concede already is that you
fawn has removed her hand from her face
so that's one thing that's different
Fabiano still still in all kinds of
awkward positions here and not not quite
yet showing us the eye but he's got his
poker face on not showing his eyes to
the opponent
poker face poker knack indeed although
it's funny because poker players say
that
to the neck that they actually have to
hide because when they get nervous
there's this pulsation in their in their
neck oh interesting I didn't know that
it makes sense when I get nervous my
neck gets really really red and I don't
even know why that is but it just gets
really really red so should that were
just sharing we're just sharing things
now so now some technique is gonna be
needed from a holy fun as you know it
looks 30 seconds for holy fun and 20
seconds left for Friday ah no but these
rooks are coming into the game as well
and I have coming to c4 trying to gain
some counter play but there's no good
real square for the knight at the moment
I mean before probably the best we can
do well a lot of blitz players are you
certainly Larry Christensen believes in
the powers of the night that in these
sort of time scramble situations being
down the exchange when you have a knight
is not the worst thing in the world that
it's certainly going to take some
technique for you fun to figure it out
and avoid those those tricky Pony tricks
in fact here's one right now with white
ganging up on the e5 pawn but rook d5
seems like it holds all everything
together and this Superman's g3 pawn now
probably if I was gonna try to play
that's why Bobby played with g3 keep
keeper honest yeah but I mean I don't
think we can even claim black is better
here anymore right I mean this is White
has managed to ninety threes in the
position yep even on rook f4 so no
matter what she does here 93 comes in Oh
super nice trick there she's forcing the
issue on the exchange of the past cheap
hunt Wow
so you're saying so you're saying that
Knight takes d5 yeah if Knight had taken
d5 there everybody rook takes f3 was
gonna lead to a winning endgame because
of the Jeep on despite being down a
full-piece so that was a super
resourceful trick and I think it's gonna
winter the game because that was nice
that was very very tricky when we
thought she had blundered 93 checks she
turns it into a winning idea right with
this rook f4 King me for hey well that's
not
whole point of tricks tricks were easy
to see them there wouldn't be very
tricky right silly rabbit tricks are for
kids I should have known better the the
match is within a game and we have 30
minutes left in the three-minute portion
here some super high quality chess being
played by both sides and we have another
French which means I'm wrong again Jen
wins again and everybody who everybody
who wagered on who you find now is
getting pretty excited right they
probably got some good odds yep
well another French another position
that I like white but okay no but this
is certainly not it nearly as aggressive
as the original tirage we saw where
where black was undermining everything
but white was all in with the whole f5
idea here this is gonna be much more of
a slower positional game right seems
that way
I kind of like white I like white in
these positions Danny just like you yeah
well I think as the black piece of sort
of maneuver on the queenside they poke
and prod for squares and access at some
point white decides okay here you got to
deal with might be three coming but as
soon as you deal with these threats I
think white decides to do things like
king h1 and g4 and you just continue to
try to manufacture things and the reason
that attack always comes into view for
those who don't
maybe our beginner chess players who
don't know this structure when you have
all your pawns facing toward one side of
the board that's where you want to
attack and so Queen e1 actually that's a
really nice way to deal with that threat
of Knight b3 gen because that Queen
wants to come over here eventually in
help in this all-out assault of the King
absolutely I love that move Queen e1
we're now is saying you know if you do
take this night off my bishop want b7 is
going to be gorgeous I think just play
g4 here anyway I think she just should
just go for it now I mean as much as we
hate losing that dark square bishop and
these lines you know okay she's willing
to give it up anyway but I was gonna say
if we give it up and we can prepare a5
and that's how white gets closer to
having an attack you're absolutely right
the key point is that even in the Blitz
game understanding that the key bishop
here is the light squared bishop because
that's the one I can go to g3 and attack
h7 the dark squared bishop might look
pretty in that square because maybe a5
later but it's not as good and with this
exchange is also that in her night
clothes her to the fray yeah and this
makes me think again that I wish she had
just played g4 and and and had the same
position but with the threat of f5 and
now now she has to deal with the b3 pawn
decides to make a trade of a 6-4 b3 and
every move you play on the other side of
the board in these positions when one
side has one chain facing this way and
you have a chain facing the other
usually every move that's played on the
Queen side kind of favors black in terms
of the tempos of the position and and
and white white finally does manufacture
a 5 here so she gets what she wants but
but I feel like black is not out of it
here he's got a rook on b3 there should
be some way for black to get enough
counter play to defend Fabi
as we saw that's like yeah I agree and
his pieces are coming to life over here
you gotta keep your eye open for taking
on d4 and take 95 in certain situations
with lots of stuff hanging in the
position for instance just even now if
it's my move is black maybe I can take
on b4 and then after you kept on e5
right
that's a nice tactic to note show the
fans here and it just a random move to
show Jen's idea of the rook and the
Queen lining up on this square for
problems which makes this pawn pin so so
that's a tactic he Faunus to be aware of
and she's thinking and she's down more
than a minute on time so after getting
her first victory in 3 minutes chefs
she's she's kind of up against it here
right now and maybe she's looking for a
way out plays rook to b1 trying to get
some pieces off the board and avoid that
pressure of the Queen and rook on e3
right okay with B 1 trying to simplify
the situation
ha okay so let's see yeah I think I
think she manages to equalize it for now
but if black takes on d4 and white takes
maybe there uh though the other rook can
come to c3 so I still feel like black is
a bit in the driver's seat because he's
already broken through on the queenside
foreplay but Fabiana doesn't see
anything concrete place a little
prophylactic move there h6 just kind of
sit and tight yeah well you know you
want immediately activating white bra
right you know you don't see Amador's
playing as much because they're like my
kings under attack I've got a tree
Queens immediately right so a very
patient right Bobby but will it backfire
as for Queen entry to pray no you please
Knight a fate kicking the Queen back
yeah she does get some squares after
that h6 the g6 squares there I didn't
lead to anything but
Queenie for threatened something
everybody if Fabiana blunders with c
takes d4 Knight takes d5 is crushing on
the spot exactly 95 the dangerous idea
and that's why I'm Bobby played Queen b3
but I wonder if his Queens the word
might backfire here will Frank yeah is
there c4 in a position no there's cream
cake C 3 that was the whole plan
we can't believe c4 here are Knights
hanging and and Queen uh Queen b3 was
aggressive in its own right right it was
defensive minded on d5 but also created
that threat of C takes d4 and and
opening up the 3rd rank for the Queen
so yifan had to find this defensive of
91 40 seconds left for the Challenger
and a minute left for the favorite in
the match so far but this has been super
close and I I don't I don't know the
Congress a good move here you don't want
to take on d4 anymore Jenn because the
knight can then take and fork the Queen
and the pony 6 ok but Fabiano says I do
like that okay we'll see he can still
play Queen b6 or even a bishop oh he's
played the more aggressive Bishop c5 but
even king h1 here
I still feel like that was it that was a
decent transition for you fun maybe even
h4 here I don't see car Warner getting
getting anything better than just taking
on d4 with the bishop and then she can
kind of fix her structure with C takes
d4 and Queen F were chosen by - I think
he met um Queen can sometimes now I got
Sonny a seven if we're not careful right
deep on before played she's hoping to
get her Knight into a better position
here with 93 and I'd have to read there
was her choice still I think that I can
I come to jean fournier I guess it
doesn't really do a whole lot so she
please page three makes them look first
but is there h4 yeah she gets h4 but and
now maybe she'll have Knight h3 Knight
f4 it's okay not anymore that that pins
the knight to f1 obviously but she does
have g4 if she wants it back here yeah
that was a nice move before so she's
played Queen before just in the nick of
time that's an important move otherwise
she was gonna end up in a big trouble I
think
but we're cat five immediately by Fabio
she's still in time or do we just have
names e6 no no she plays she three I got
I got a bad feeling about this game that
it may be the first one that gives us
our peaceful result it's headed seems to
be headed toward an ecocash oh look
who's nice pointing out the Queen guards
d1 and so she's still kind of sitting
tight can she I know she can't quite I
thought maybe she could trade on at five
and if each takes play the move Knight
f2 with temple on the Queen maybe she
could have gone for that actually rook
takes f5 e takes a five and then Knight
f2 with tempo on the Queen and she might
be getting the better night ending yeah
I'm gonna say no time to calculate that
she's living on the increment here and
actually
yeah i jinxed the peaceful result of
hair the it may still we still get a
peaceful results despite the blunder but
the time yes she's getting some
counterplay year in need the time really
seems to be the issue now and she's her
night on f4 well she she she's black
daddy so she was down to like a second
or two right now with a bunch of fast
moves she's managed to build a backpack
right love that increment yeah but it
still it's it's definitely one that is
super dangerous these night endings are
not nearly as close to a draws of rook
endings when you're only up upon the
night's can really kind of kind of
maneuver and outplay each other giving
the person with the extra pawn a pretty
good advantage alright but she's doing
well she's created a target for her
night on h6 which is gonna make sure
this King stays stays nice and put right
there on g7 that's right so what they
say about night in games and night
hanging are like pawn end games or
similar names because you can't really
easily lose a tempo in situations right
you can't with the bishops in the rocks
like same old no moves okay see he
almost gets a perpetual there but
Fabiano was just sort of tricky why not
nice c4 I thought but okay the night
comes to g2 and I guess it's gonna come
to f4 and then to e4 and Fabiano's
almost worked himself back into a win
here but no I think I think she finally
got him stuck he's now really kind of
stuck to this e6 pawn and and I and I
don't think that and I don't think she's
gonna well I didn't jinx it enough
apparently so we do have our first
peaceful results of the match that we
are we're nearly two hours in and we've
only had one draw
I think that's getting what the gaming
what the people paid for here and oh and
he plays an unusual line offering up a
Sicilian with a six and
father goes for the c3 Sicilian because
she's kind of committed to playing a
less correctly viable line of the c3
Sicilian so your little opening nuance
is there for both players and Queen b3
yeah get the better end game here and oh
you find without much choice because he
could have maybe taken on c5 she
retreated the Queen this is very similar
to a French now right I mean it's not a
French but we're kind of in a French
structure almost but the problem is that
a six pawn might be able to batter it
with the p45 it's white so I got a like
white position here
yeah I agree that's kind of a key point
to why you allow these double pawns
everybody is that oh and there we go
that open file becomes so useful and
here Fabiano is using it for tactics
isn't Bishop to d6 check coming ooh yep
gonna go down the exchange here you fawn
is it seems like something went wrong
they're allowing this this nice tactic
let's see what happened thereafter
Knights Aditi exchange Danny can you
play with catchy flavor k7 oh yeah
that's 97 so she's not he's not going
after right away this prefer a little
for a minute see what you do yeah an
instructive point here was on night 2 d2
she played Knight e to c6 when she
probably probably should have played
either Knight c8 everybody to anticipate
these weak dark squares or maybe even
Knight B to C 6 so that's kind of an
instructive little tactic because this
is the type of position that people can
get in their own games with an open a
file early to see to see what happened
there so assuming Faviana was gonna get
Knight c7 here and go on to win the
exchange an interesting little little
blunder out of the opening there she's
up she's up on time though I was gonna
say I was about to say Bishop b8 saves
the rook up no it doesn't it's actually
Bishop e8 does save the rook it just it
just has other problems tricky little
mates before I actually really liked
that idea maybe he could have played
Knight g5 last move Jenin I guess Knight
takes e5 would have been the problem
indeed silly silly rabbits tricks are
for kids we're always looking for him
but our f6 is played he fought is she's
trying to wiggle her way out of this
despite being really in kind of a tight
spot here with the king he's not playing
this line when they see 7 is that after
work a7 Bishop a 7 9 8 7 where does the
knight on c7 go yeah that's that's weird
Wow bizarre yeah hey let's show the fans
that I was a good line gen 97 rook a
seven if takes and takes the point is
the knight can't get really get out
you've got night a8 but maybe then
Bishop d8 and so Fabiano worried he's
gonna end up losing two pieces for the
rook instead of winning the exchange so
being very careful here and maybe he
doesn't need to Jen I mean look at
blacks pieces on the Queen side right I
mean there's like almost no moves here
for blacks pieces right like giving up
my beautiful bishop on b6 really makes a
lot of sense for your checkmated rook on
a Hey right absolute like that excited
to give up either my knight on d5 or my
my bishop one b6 for that Brook which is
garbage right yep very good intuitive
play by Fabiano that don't be
materialistic it's not about how much
your pieces are worth it's about what
they're doing and even in blitz that's
that's the amazing thing about these
superb players the best in the world but
they judge these things even in a blitz
game so quickly
yeah I agreed and rook g4 is kind of a
weird move cuz it doesn't seem to do
anything and but but I guess it poses a
question to white all right my position
is bad but she's saying how are you
gonna get me right
so Fabiano has to figure out some way to
take advantage of this ridiculously
awesome looking bind over here on the
king and rook right and yeah you're
right a bit about who are you finally so
you just have to play moves you know
like trying to sit here and but best
advice Levon Aronian ever gave me in bug
houses just move just move it so much
easier said than done I believe players
in the world who are gonna be like what
well yeah the point is if you don't see
mate most often and bug outs the best
move is just to move quickly but okay
yeah and blitz okay it's certainly not
the same but it is there is something to
be said for you know not necessarily
trying to you know don't beat yourself
if you don't see a win play quickly here
and then at now she's taking a little
bit of time but you know despite how
ugly the position looks Fabiano hasn't
found a concrete way to win yet yeah I
mean also impressive fighting abilities
by a holy fun strongest active woman on
the planet right now I mean as you
pointed out Judah pulled our only player
higher rated than her oh wow so she was
calculating something and I couldn't
figure out what it was but this is what
it was some sort of sacrifice to unwind
the camp but but it doesn't look really
good for riot it does I didn't
understand I mean at first I thought
opening the bishop was gonna give her
some kind of immediate tactic on the
pond but indeed no that is not what was
happening she just she just felt like
she could sit on the position anymore
and so she went all in but this is great
even Knight takes a I was gonna say
Knight takes a 6 there I was wondering
if that was possible with was some sort
of craziness Bishop takes a 6 and and
maybe maybe a win immediately on the C
file that that might have actually been
even better than than what Fabien or did
but this is gonna be really good too
because a six is gonna hang in these
variations as well Danny 96 as possible
but take some d5 even better yeah well
at this point yeah it looks like he's uh
up a piece he's up a piece and the piece
is a piece whether Knight takes a six
worked or not
and I think Fabiana was just gonna take
the point here yep and holy Fon throws
in the towel we are back to decisive
chess ladies and gentlemen no more draws
and a two point lead with about 15
minutes remaining in the three-minute
portion but this is a close match as you
said Jen if it's within a game or two
that's what happens when you get to
bullet if it's within a game or two then
it's anybody's game and right now that's
all whole you phone can ask for it's
just gonna be a precursor to the fight
on Saturday much closer than everybody
else thought I have no idea I'm a big
believer that this is a lot of hype and
for Mayweather is gonna take that one
but okay I'm not a I'm not a boxing
commentator so no idea but but then
you're so far I I would say that this
match is so much closer than people
thought agreed it's to two points
distance but it could be even closer of
course there was that horrendous mouth
clip in the 960 but I mean this could go
anyway as we approach the bullet I just
think they if I need to keep a two point
distance if she gets down further than
that it's gonna be very troubling yes oh
this game super important
whatever Fabiano did with his camera we
appreciate it because now we can even
see that he's eating something that
looked like a protein bar so he's he's
trying to keep his trying to keep his
energy level up I wish I had a protein
bar right about now protein bar of
choice Jen um well no I don't really
like them either just fuel what about
you yeah I'm not a fan of protein bars
but I think I'll go with a Clif Bar
sometimes they're not the worst thing
quest bars used to be amazing but then
they messed up the recipe yeah are you
saying like the Tigers milk protein bars
but there's a lot of sugar on those ones
so just boil some eggs just boil some
eggs that's true cage free eggs though
that's right
cage free eggs all right all right well
let's go on here we got Queen g5 of
ork of the G and E pawns but but queen
of two we'll probably just solve that I
would guess unless she you know what
she's thinking about
she's thinking about counseling long I
bet you she's thinking about just
counseling long hair Jenna and saying
are you really gonna take that cheap on
no not going to write if she castles
long G pawn maybe then the rook comes
over and and but yes defended it with
Queen f3 and then no but I think she was
planning it the whole time she goes for
it next move and and I agree that this
was probably the way to go for her was
to cast along and try to get some kind
of attack on the Kings side all right
well we're gonna see what happens now
with the attack on with Kings on both
sides of the board it's uh it's all in
for the attack our favorite kind of
chess the thing here about the position
that's hard for white is again you wish
you can move this pawn from a3 back to a
2 and B 3 is a way to deal with that but
the point everybody is if a four- B 4
and if B 4 you have a 4 this is a common
defensive theme to kind of make note of
when you're under fire via a pawn storm
you create this little anchor situation
of the pond so that you can meet either
break through with in advance to keep
the position closed whereas if you had
not done that let's say white did
something else then b4 would have come
and a 4 is not possible of course so an
instructive little moment there but
you've on to defend Caruana goes for it
anyway what sorry what you are Danny
that's really impressive I've you know I
come up with instructive moments in
bullet games
literally for a living because it's the
only quality chess I play anymore no I'm
kidding no I blunder for a living but no
there's some tend to be a believer that
there are always instructive moments to
find in these games even though as the
great Nesbitt Dean off would say only a
fool analyzes blitz but I am a fool so I
will analyze blitz and try to find
instructive moments love it well what
about this Mookie need to instruct like
I like it I think see it she's worried
about the thief
yeah but I think she's gonna play Queen
Oh for now yeah and if she can offer
this Queen trade if if he doesn't trade
then d6 is weak Queen Queen c3 check the
punish you for putting your king on be
there yeah that's a bit of a problem
yeah actually what what is what does
yuvan do now actually Queen c3 check is
it's coming we probably have to run and
try to play something like can meet you
and rook D to hold hold everything
together
yeah King E - what do you think in kingi
- but if Queen C 3 roof D - you can take
on d3 and and then at the end of
deadline b3 falls yeah you're right
b3 hand or which is even worse yeah this
is backfiring for Yvonne and she's kind
of shuffling in her chair she decides to
go all in and now she's she's kind of
pot committed to open up the center
despite the fact that the king is not
where it wants to be go back and forth I
thought you might but she didn't yeah I
I agreed with you I thought that that
was that was what was coming you think
this isn't too bad either
although it looks pretty bad who she
gets d6 though I mean what what in the
world right I mean you know what's her
coming on d6 is if the bishop just moves
like Bishop takes a four she's gonna
play e5 maybe got a whole bunch of
nachos it's wild it's a lot of passed
pawns but but I don't know if it's
enough because if Bishop takes a four
ePHI Bishop b5 check Black's gonna pick
up the rook but something tells me that
black should be just winning in this
game but you know it's blitz and so
maybe it was the right practical shot
for her anyway gen given that she kind
of made this mistake with the King on D
- yeah it was all that something we're
talking about Danny but the thing was
that Bobby had a back-up plan to open up
the C file so even though she
neutralized a and me yet C yo so or that
C file every time gets me so rook takes
f5 tricky Queenie
if work takes out 526 Jack he doesn't go
for that
he plays Queen c3 instead with this
devastating idea of Bishop b5
you won't be able to play King up to
then because I get Queen tasty to
attract yeah this is this is becoming a
problem everybody because this gem is
saying that if Bishop b5 check comes you
can't go here because the rook and you
can't go to e1 because the Queen takes
c3 so Queen to c3 was a really strong
move and and you found so much so she's
gotta go out of her way with the Queen
just to stop Bishop to b5 check but here
it comes again
should be three same diagonal different
square that is a problem in fact it may
be enough to just win the game here I
mean with no time on the clock whether
there's a saving move or not she's
probably not going to have the
wherewithal to find it okay so she goes
d6 but here comes chat Kingi
Oh King d1 but the mating net is on will
it close looks like it
the Queen has exact result b3 would
force the the sacrifice well not a
sacrifice of the Queen the loss of the
Queen but it's another game for holy fun
can she get back in that 2-point
distance and scout the game from from
favi the match is now at a three point
lead for the first time since it was
four to one right to start the match so
this is the biggest lead he's matching
his biggest lead we have not seen a four
game lead we have seen a three game lead
early on if you're just joining us and
seven minutes left in the three minute
portion it's been a close match but
Fabiano right now proving to be the
better player by just a few games we're
back in an Enzo Indian Queen's Indian
type structure we haven't seen this
interval in a little while yeah this is
the most traditional and invisible that
we've seen we've seen some kind of like
weird Queen's Indian one where Bobby
even managed to Castle queenside but
here we've got kind of the traditional
battle for the e4 square and the two
bishops gained by fabien yeah I have to
like this type of mine for white it
seems it seems just a little easier to
play he's just getting to expand now
without three and a four and those two
bishops are going to be hard to meet
especially in a blitz game I tend to
like black in these positions I think
just from my own experience of playing
the nimzo-indian but
the main thing is can you deal with the
big center here you'd like to play
something like 97 and get e5 or really
you'd like to get e5 and actually have
your night to be able to come over to a5
where were you and the knight and the
bishop can kind of meet me on c4 but
good i love the disagreement i don't
play this with white or black anymore i
used to play the names oh but i found
myself struggling in positions like this
because the FBI would also get yanked Oh
BAM yep f4 and f5 is the other idea yeah
no I agree and I think this is this is a
sign that the position is less than
ideal as far as an ideal NIMS over black
anyway because as I was saying if you
could get whatever you want I'll just do
that real quick on the analysis board to
provide whatever instruction we can
let's just say if black could get what
you want you really want this you want
it to be closed but this knight needs to
be here with the bishop so that you can
get enough counterplay on the queenside
to justify whatever black is gonna have
to deal with over here on the Kings side
so when ninety seven comes in a four I
like this move by white a four and a
five and white gets to kind of play the
whole board here gin and have a have a
nice Center advantage to go with it
and E five isn't as good anymore because
if you get e5 as black and these
positions they play d5 and the Knights
are sort of stepping on each other's
toes here they're not they're not that
useful on d7 and f6 and and White's
gonna come with f4 at some point and
open up the Kings side oh wow she takes
in Polly five that's because she's got
the c5 square under under her her view
there for the night that's not a bad
idea gen if you get the knight to c5
then it's a lot harder for white to get
out for because the e4 pawn will be weak
yeah it's a lot it's a lot less it's
more unusual but that's why she's such a
great player firing these interesting
ideas but it still seems so much easier
to play this with the with the potential
weakness on v6 as well coming into the
game agree who the position of my knight
on h3 that's the question if I could
stick it on f5 that would be amazing
that's gonna take a lot of moves o night
f2 to d1 to e3
I thought he likes your idea though I
think he's oh nice tactic that is a that
is a hedgehog tactic you got to take
advantage when you
have less space and I say it
instinctively whether it works or not
just because I look at d5 and I know
that if black hadn't done something like
this as you said the Knights just gonna
relocate we're gonna get a position
where black is just getting squeezed so
we'll see if she can fully justify it
but I like that move d5 well my issue
what about work 87 here you don't have
to ship say c6 because it takes on d5 so
you got to go back to AAA and want to
make sure that nothing ugly is happening
there yeah I know it is it is scary I'm
a little worried about it should be five
position I think that's the right move I
agree with you Bishop e5 looks looks
strong renews the threat of taking on d5
everybody because now there's no bishop
on e2 Unitas would allow pawn to avoid
the loss no no you can maybe I don't
know after after Knight to f6 I think we
have Bishop f6 cuz if you play Knight
takes f6 we have work east seven rook
takes e7 rook takes Queen in the end
white ends up winning a piece because of
that Bishop on b5 so I agree with you
and and Fabiano does too so he takes it
are we gonna are we gonna see that that
was just a miscalculation by youth on
certainly she doesn't want to take with
the pawn if you ask me an Queen a
totally lost right yeah just totally
lost well I think she just missed that I
think she probably calculated quickly
that she could do not have six cuz the
Queen was on d2 hanging and just missed
the rook on e8 and I think that
resignation kind of tells us that that's
the case so so we have a Ford lately
Rick a7 I mean I don't know if Bobby saw
all that when he played Nike night that
he won but that's fantastic work a7 it's
it's it's it hurts right I still think
she did the right thing I mean she was
getting squeezed they're not an ideal
NIMS Oh with the night on d7 once white
gets that a file open but she tried to
make d5 work and Fabiano just playing
playing a high-level brain to chess and
execute it perfectly now he's got a
four-game lead the largest of the match
so far Jen if she wins this game we're
back to a three-game lead head into the
bullet
we only have a minute and 45 seconds
left before we are in the fastest
portion of the match but it's gonna be a
really exciting bullet portion but holy
fun
you just got to look at the scoreboard
it she's really up against it
absolutely well we'll see if if you
strike back here I don't you know we've
we've had we've had four games lead four
game leads overcome and bullet before
Jen in the history of these matches that
we've done on chess comm we have never
had a five game deficit overcome so so
that was she would be playing against
history as well as a very strong
American Grandmaster if she loses this
one what she's made history she's become
the women's world champion here's the
besides Judith the only woman to break
2,700 I believe so she knows about
making history managed to make it here
that's right well we we have 960 coming
up right after this everybody don't go
anywhere the regardless of the result
here we will immediately move into
chess960 before a very quick break and
then bullet chess for our two players
here this will for sure be the last game
in the three-minute barring a blunder in
the next five seconds and someone
resigning we've got only 30 seconds left
and we've got a we've got a Spanish we
haven't had one of these in a little
while yeah that's right Fabiano was
switching over to the French defense
which was going which was really leading
to some extremely rich games yeah no it
was and a good chance for us to agree
that we both liked white but we didn't
get good results I guess with the Ilia
meeting meeting you thought I don't know
if she got the best results against the
French she won that one really nice game
counter-attacking in the Blitz game so
obviously Carolina is a higher rated
super Yuliya player we'd love to see how
you feel fun join those ranks with her
outstanding victory in Beals she seems
to be headed in that direction but right
now Bobby is the world-class player and
he was just playing some amazing
counterpunching chess there
apparently we're both wrong and that
holy fun actually has never crossed
2,700 yet she made 2687 okay that's what
I wasn't sure about I knew that no other
woman made 2,700 but okay she's very
close right having her yeah I know right
now she's around she's even a little
lower than that right you're getting
there and I think she will
yep I agree I think she will she's 26 69
now but expecting that she will get
there on her career as well well let's
see what she can do in her career right
now she's white in this Spanish I think
white has a little bit of an edge here
black is preparing things like f5
everybody but playing f5 comes with a
lot of double-edged double-edged NISS is
that a word I don't know but it opens up
White's LightSquared Bishop on c2 so
well oh well he does it I was gonna say
we know it's the natural plan for black
every piece is staring at the square and
he decides to do it I think you phone's
gonna take on f5 once and then maybe
play f4 or or what you do something yeah
it maybe take a 5 in the night h5 I
think f4 9h five seem to be the natural
so yeah the issue before after ephors
you don't have this this bishop open
anymore that's why I was a little
hesitant but but maybe she could
organize some sort of undermining yeah I
was gonna say can she organized 9 h5 in
g4 and we are about to be all-in with
some crazy chess here let's see g4 come
on come on almost come on I want to see
g4 before this match is done I still
wanted to see g4 there and a full
undermining but but ok
the process was mighty white right I was
gonna say yeah that's yeah those night
George
she's just shuffling there's not active
idea so she's just gonna shuffle and see
what black comes up way well plus
without g4 and without the undermining
the East war the e4 square those nights
are kind of they're kind of married to
each other right no
a superfluous I know you know we'll
leave that for ya sir the the know I was
gonna say there it's like a
dysfunctional marriage they're married
to each other on g3 and h5 whether they
like it or not but but okay she found a
way she found a way out of that she had
a prenup got those nights out of there
so uh she's got Queen h5 now and she
actually did manage to get the nights
out of that kind of weird weird spot and
maybe she's gonna redouble her efforts
for g4 again although now would be a
very risky time to do that with the
night h4 ideas coming what's going on
here 90 h4 is coming anyway so what why
did she play 93 mmm-hmm well this this
idea of communicating is very dangerous
and it's gonna force the move Bishop f2
I thought now okay night h5 is also
holding on to all the marbles for the
moment but now Brooke takes g2 is
threatened I mean you can't play g3
because of Knight f3 so Queen f1 but
what's gonna happen against Fabiano a
simple plan of just doubling up the
rocks yeah I don't know something I you
know I know it's hard to find a way to
manufacture that's one of those things
were in a classical game with more time
you would find a way to be a little more
accurate maybe maybe tactically do the
work that makes you feel like you could
get away with something like g4 but here
it feels like the Knights kind of you
know jumped around for a while didn't
get enough and now the G file is
becoming useful for for the second
player instead of white and and I I
agree I start to like black and you fall
and starts to go into the think tank
yeah well how is he gonna protect you
two enough I guess you're gonna have to
play rookie - but there's Bishop b5 yeah
I just feel like she stops that yeah she
needs to play c4 and then after Rick g8
now Ricky - but but still it feels like
Knight f3 check is coming I feel like
we're headed towards some sort of
brilliant sacrifice inmate this Queen's
gonna come to h5 we're gonna get a sack
on h3 and then Knight f3 and and some
sort of like Knight ourf Zurich
International 1953 game here this looks
like black is about to go to sack town
I love it Sactown that's a nice one
yeah I like the way you're thinking
about this but does Knight f3 work right
now maybe not just yet
although you're right it actually may be
Islam or something I thought but there's
also Bishop ei coming into h5 I feel
like black just holds all the cards
whether it's Bishop e8 Bishop h5 you
know bring the Queen to the G file yeah
he now Bishop Miege 5 it's devastating
she's played Queen e1 I'm trying to take
on g3 young and maybe no sacs needed
here maybe just Bishop h5 let her take
on g3 and then take each okay no she
decides I mean he decides I'm not gonna
even let her let her out of that net and
renews the threat of taking on g2 by
bringing the Queen to to g7 yeah it's a
lot of people it takes g2 just game over
no I mean I think that's what he was
renewing with Queen to g7 Knight takes
g2 is uh it's a problem isn't it ok this
is also a problem very nice nice way to
finish off the game with mate there yeah
you saw that coming though Danny Queen
h4 and he saw the whole thing through
impressive the Queen's coming to h5
everybody and white is mated and the
chess960 game is on just got to show the
finish of that because we did kind of
see it coming we said there was gonna be
something nasty and look at that so
wowzers and show that line one more time
great game you know this that it was
that was a really lovely attack there
from Aviano
and now we've got a fissure in Fischer
960 Fischer random again and we'll find
out if we can avoid some mouse slips in
this game we had mutual mouth what's
going on last time
you know mouth ups and blenders are
gonna be more likely in 960 because
these pieces are in such odd
configurations particularly the Knights
so as both players struggle to get
coordinated well we'll see you which way
castling occurs the Queen on H 1 and H 8
or so poorly placed an e so Bobby
decides to lash out with H or yeah I
like it I mean the one thing as bad as
having the Knights in the center maybe
not quite as bad is that or sorry the
Knights on the edge is having the Queen
on the edge another way I've lost chance
960 games is never quite getting the
Queen in a dominant position like she
wants to be so I think your white will
play b3 and just a fence c4 and then try
to get back to that plan of Queen h3
unless you see something a little more
dynamic as far as how to defend c4 but
but okay we're you know you're in it
you're in territory here where if she
can win this game she does bring it back
to four games before we head into bullet
so she's you know and certainly we know
there's enough time and enough games
played usually about as many bola games
played in these matches as there are in
the five and three-minute combined so
don't go anywhere anybody I'm sure we
are gonna see something oh look at that
I love those castles that's how you do
it that's how you castle along in
chess960 she figured it out nice to know
that she she pays attention to our notes
that we sent her and zoom that's the
most important thing now anyway that she
listened at least Noah did show that you
know as someone who's struggling as we
host these shows with you know
production and communication with the
players and all the commentary we're
doing I'm always happy to know that
something went right on a technical
level all right there we go another
castles not not quite as pretty as you
Fonz was yeah well maybe FS what yeah f6
and ePHI that's what I want to see
although let's find more ways to trap
that Queen on h8 that's the problem with
f6 yeah she's not into it
she plays aged six and maybe she's gonna
try to get g5 but this is a tough
position I mean look at that Queen right
I mean the Queen is kind of dealing with
the bishop on
b1 the bishop on f4 is just it's not
easy to get her out into the game that's
right so this is how how Fabia
anticipated things earlier he's bringing
his queen out to h3
thinking about putting the Queen on g3
or perhaps moving the Knight to e5 and
then the Queen has so many choices of
squares
19-7 is a threat guys yeah they take 7s
maybe I just me that's right we know you
like this commentary more than the same
they don't I have a great time it's
wonderful
yeah those say the one thing the st.
Louis commentary says I have to say have
a ton of respect for how you yes Ann
Marie's hang in there because some of
those shows right I mean how insane does
it get when you get one of those 80 plus
Move games and you guys are there for
seven hours I mean if not for not for
yes or forcing the crew to take breaks
you guys would be in big trouble right
it's like on breaks everybody's like oh
my god and then as soon as the mics turn
on they're like back in action anyway
because there is a yes easy 7 is hanging
and that's a that's weird and again this
is it seems funny because we I was just
sort of obviously I was pointing it out
because the beginning of the game the
Queen's were in the corner but it is
kind of what's gonna happen here you it
this happens in these kind of weird
chess960 s1 side gets the Queen active
and the other doesn't but it's okay for
black I mean aftertaste on see fence I
mean Queen e7 there's always rip t7
right so why is this a good sacrifice uh
you got I mean it's well he's gonna take
c5 and yes no question is how many pawns
has he gotten I mean okay I see what
you're saying it is a lot of pawns for
and actually Bishop a fight was a
fantastic move because if the rook moves
now Queen takes c5 wins more than the
pawns and maybe will win the night on d6
so I actually think that white is in the
driver's seat here and and and now now
she now he's gonna get c5 with Shaq take
on d7 and so it's strange and that's one
of those
weird dynamics about chess960 once I
gets the initiative and it's even worse
than a real game because the other side
never reached optimal development
coordination anyway exactly and this is
a class rubric before stopping queen G
for gaining counterplay um and in
threatening just work to do you want and
so it looks like it's gonna force black
into the Queen exchange with Queen c6
but that looks like too many pawns to
grapple with doesn't it yeah I agree
a lot of pawns here and the two and the
rook is already dominant over the minor
pieces having control over the D file
here and and if what you said about
poker the one thing that you know you
notice that L is the neck then we know
we've seen a lot of Fabiano's neck today
and we know his neck has been pretty
calm so his neck seems pretty calm and I
think I think he feels in control of
this one and f3
we got a knight on d6 falling and yifan
needs this break she needs to pull
herself together and come back for an
epic fight in the bullet yeah but this
has been like such a high quality I know
in so many games both sides and yes so
she she throws in the towel she knows
it's time for a break takes a quick peek
at the camera and Jen you and I take a
quick moment to look at the score remind
everybody so we have a six game leave
for the favorite heading in but I feel
like the chess has been super close and
high-quality by both sides and and you
know in the critical moments
Fabiano has just been that much better a
little bit better yeah it's been it's
been really wonderful to see you oh you
found part of the speed Chess
Championships and of course we would
have liked to see this match being even
closer but the chess has really treated
us despite that agree totally and on the
note of the general speech s
championship let's remind everybody that
it is brought to you by masterclass
during this break here's the bracket
again to show you that the winner of
this match here between Fabiano Caruana
and holy fawn will take on Hikaru
Nakamura
so they got a tough opponent waiting for
them as we move into the quarterfinals
we will have we will only have one side
of the bracket left to know which is
Magnus Carlsen and engineer goo CNF and
then of course Maxime Boucher
LaGravenese Jeffrey Zhang which is next
week on August 30th so tons of great
players in this event this year it is
sponsored by masterclass so let's do our
due diligence and remind you that the
one the only the 13th world champion did
a course with masterclass and the thing
I'm excited to see Jen I'm actually
excited to see what happens in the
opening portion cuz apparently he's
revealing novelties and if it happens to
be about the Scotch one of my favorite
openings I'll be happy to see what his
novelties are yeah that sounds like a
bath let's let's take a quick peek at
this commercial again we'll try not to
do commentary over it even though we've
seen it a bunch of times and have fun
watching gary play assignable against
these people in this commercial check
[Music]
but it's not just check stand attacks
you have to be creative
let's come with King g5 King c2 king of
six can be speaking g17c 14 to 16 before
Kings a certain cases boom what lost yes
twin takes then Knight f5 and it's a
double attack so let's go back and see
what's the next logical gross
skewer and attraction and this mate
what an amazing mate I've been thinking
about few ideas that I never used what I
want to show that's one of my favorite
oh wait it's not about winning or losing
but of course at the end of the day it's
about whatever I'm Gary Kasparov and
this is my master
and we're back Jen we are getting set to
start the one minute portion Fabiano is
back in his chair we are waiting for you
Phan in just a moment she will be here
hopefully soon we don't want the clock
to start early in this one because it's
only a bullet so I'm sure shal oh yeah
he hooked it I know it's very early in
the morning in Beijing where what you
find is playing from right I was lucky
enough to go to Beijing a couple of
times well what what an absolute
eye-opener it is to travel all over the
world because of chess and it's great
that speed chess chance kind of shows
off that international flavor of Giles
yeah we're lucky we get to bring all
these players together in a way that is
lets them play too from their own homes
from a convenient environment right I
think the the webcam angle as we
continue to improve things and the
technology gets better and better this
sort of personal look at these players
is just it's a lot of fun and of course
it's led to some pretty fun moments
seeing their facial expressions and
sometimes some music these two have been
pretty straight faced today right we've
had not a lot of not a lot of animated
we've seen a lot of Fabiano car Juana's
neck line we've seen a lot of ho ye
fawns left hand
no I'm kidding no we've seen these two
have been pretty pretty serious not an
itch Giri who was who was bouncing to
music pretty much the entire time so and
with that the last 30 minutes of this
match is underway Jen the bullet has
begun and it looks like both players are
ready to whip out their moves fast and
furious that's what we like to see I
love this opening choice by ho you find
four bullet agreed and we've got the
score there for everyone to follow
certainly it is it's an uphill battle
right now but it starts with one win at
a time to use a cliche phrase from
sports since I look for every
opportunity to do that
one game at a time one win at a time and
we'll see if she can do that certainly
she's uh she's white now and an opening
we haven't really seen yet some kind of
creative little Kings Indian attack
right Jen I mean we've seen efore we've
seen Sicilians so this is this is the
first time opening here yeah just an
opening where she can make a lot of fast
moves is why I'm a really good bullet
choice I think right and we see it has
worked as she has a slight time
advantage over Fabiano and her totally
on yeah I'll be interested to see how I
have no idea how holy fun is a bullet
Jen I know that Fabiano is obviously has
been the stronger player and we
certainly know he's a world-class GM but
you know I don't know the bullet is his
biggest strength necessarily right I
mean he he was in a super close match
last year with MDL and Maxime really
tend to define his way in the bull and
kind of pulled away a little bit so
we'll see how far beyond a place in in
the bullet portion here right now
you fought it's just up a pond isn't she
she just won upon straight up straight
up pulling you got upon us upon how many
times has that cliche phrase been said
in chess a pawn is a pawn well not
counting not counting Georgie catches
really let's take away the obvious
person who over uses it I'm just a dirty
pawn grabber a pawn is a point when we
know we know yes or loves pawns so all
right well he's got some compensation
though this knight on d4 is super strong
this is this is gonna be a little tricky
for for white to to deal with that pony
but but you know here she goes she's got
a majority a five is hanging maybe you
take on d5 and just go gobble a second
point I kind of like pawns and we you
know we both like pawns let's go get
another pawn take a five but she started
with this in-between move Queenie for
getting her Queen out of any potential
Disco's oh but even nicer actually I
think that she's uh maybe not maybe as
much as that look fun mmm how super out
of the blue shot and the queen is in
trouble because the pawn on e5 was pin
oh I thought there was Queen c6 check in
that position nope and now she's gonna
go down because she's losing the rook
that was a that was a horrible even
better sorry yeah I was thinking Queen
c6 was good but knight c6 just forced
his resignation yeah that was a tough
and a tough set of circumstances there
everybody the the whole point right here
on the analysis board as you can see is
there's a there's a skewer here the two
rooks she got herself in trouble
actually with this move Knight to e3
which cut off the protection of the
Queen and walked right into this amazing
f5 shot taking advantage of the fact
that omphh asan couldn't work so doing
our best to keep our viewers entertained
and educated as the bullet goes on we
already know that's gonna get harder and
harder to do but I just wanted to take a
second to show that tactic and we're
already in another interesting game with
an isolated Queen pawn here I love these
games for for white and and I kind of
like them for black too yeah this is
what I also play for both sides sorry go
ahead
oh I was just gonna say a lot of people
in the chatter commenting on holy funds
low bullet rating of course that is
because she hasn't played a lot of
bullet on chess calm she is clearly way
stronger than that so don't get too
excited about how your bullet rating is
way better than yep uh-huh
challenger after this the it'll be
interesting to see what happens if she
wins just a couple games how much her
rating will jump up should be fun right
because she's uh slightly underrated if
she was playing at Caracara would be
very upset about about the rating
difference because we know he loves his
3,000 bullet rating
everybody loves 3,000 I who doesn't love
3,000 right Dragon Ball Z you know what
I'm saying
the that little thread of Bishop f6 in
Bishop e4 yes but um what about even in
this position I'm starting to worry
about the Kings side because of Bishop
f6 in Queens III 94 type stuff that oh
that's very dangerous work community or
to start also looks really introduced
right yep Queen h4 h7 is gonna fall and
the attack is on for white this is what
happens in these isolated queen pawn
positions at least if white gets
gets his way this type of attack
everybody and and it's trouble I mean I
think white even has choices like Knight
takes f7 okay goes with Knight to c4 and
maybe we'll have a relocation party for
this Knight 93 Knight g4 or something
like that
relocation party sounds like it's a very
exciting party it's usually a party a
moving party yeah nothing like tricking
your friends into helping you move I
bring beer yep I get no you bring beer
that's right
Oh in the Queen's of come off the board
that was a little unexpected and now for
scene IV to to keep the material should
be 393 and a white is diamonds for prom
but they recalled a blunder I'm go Bobby
oh no blunders right back and now who's
better because this Bishop is better
than the night in an open position
ending Fabiana finding some tricks
though the person who's better as a
person with more time it looks like
because this is getting to be those wild
bullet contacts or as Larry Christianson
says player with the night tends to be
better right whoever has the night has a
huge advantage maybe I was gonna say I
think maybe time for her to just trade
the rooks on d2 she goes for it and she
has 31 won so you know there's there's
potential that she can have the majority
that's that's a little more effective if
she can get these Queens excuse me Queen
side pawns rolling yeah and now losing
my voice after mate way too many hours
of chess TV this week don't worry I got
ya if you have any problems I'll just
start talking right I can always I can
always talk less that's what my co-host
had to tell me oh no no it's it's it's
great I mean 93 94 we got it
b3 this past pawn for who you find us
gonna get a game in here I I like it
right now I
but the problem is will she will she be
able to put that Knight and King insuk's
wrong right because right now this
knight in pawn or oh they were holding
the black King back and but he's
relocated to e4 but again we need to get
our kings of the game to win this yeah
and and it looks like he's smartly
realized Fabiano smartly realized his
King was doing the defensive job on b1
so he just wants to go get rid of all of
all the blacks
the pollens yeah very nice and we're
gonna yeah
just it looks like in no she's not gonna
lie don't want her to lose on time well
it's a pretty small results they just
drawn by agreement there so I think that
was our second draw of the match so
tying for the other match that you
mentioned where there was only two draws
have we seen a loss on time today Jen no
I don't think so I think that also might
we might be about to make history with
that uh maybe Mike and I mean that's a
big stat I don't know I mean 20 minutes
left the bullet
I was corrected by my pop culture
reference to Dragon Ball Z I always have
to correct myself for pop culture snafus
it's over 9000 for my Klein tells me
there's no way he's researching whether
any whether it's the first match of
someone losing all time come on Mike
come on Mike this is where you earn your
journalism of America Award right here
for the most amazing research ever all
right what do we got here we got another
Kings Indian attack another position
where White's able to make a bunch of
moves fast we'll see if that strategy
continues by yifan and bullet for his
King side expansion
she's stuck a knight on d5 I like that
yep you if a trade happens here
everybody the C file will become a
problem for black with the weak c7 pawn
so that's that's kind of White's idea
right it's like a reverse Sicilian yeah
story of grandpré Sicilian right yeah so
G Phi which is a typical expansion here
and we'll see if f4 is played f4 would
be the typical reverse grand-prix shot
here maybe but I can't see a four
actually exact where we're also be
pressuring and Queen takes e5 is the
idea here because in 95 there should be
seven very nice yeah but before before
played and there's a long die I had over
that
one g7 which has been Obon this is gonna
be interesting black is gonna play queen
h5 and and bring the night end and try
to order orchestrate f4 but white is
white is ahead of the race oh and that's
a very nice move she picks up d6 I think
she's clearly clearly better now yeah
and she's gonna stick a mission 25 which
is a lovely position for that Bishop
it'll also be threatening things like d5
that was a nice move right there fabien
are not gonna let his pawns on the beef
I'll become sitting ducks he
aggressively creates chances and now if
they're open I see 95s coming does she
miss that hmm I wonder because although
she's prepared to sack the Queen okay so
our first Queen sacked by Yifan we've at
least had one by each player so that's
cool brilliant sacrifice is making my
kind are not quite the same you're right
but but nonetheless though I mean is she
really worse here I mean this is this is
a rook of minor in a pawn and I can't
say that oh but she blunders the rook Oh
heartbreaking biggest blunder we saw of
the entire match just like I hang my
piece which is which says a lot to the
quality of chess we've seen Jen I agree
I mean that's the first time we've seen
like like just you know kind of hand to
the forehead blunder right just like
oops totally it's pretty impressive and
that except that mouse lit by Fabien yum
in the 960m that's right that's right
now I guess excluding the mouse well
okay a couple a couple big wins here so
far in the bullet portion for Fabiano
but games certainly that last one that
you fond didn't really have any business
losing before the blunder so we'll see
if she can get herself a couple
victories and she's almost entering the
mathematical not possible to come back
territory I guess it's not quite there
yet we won't we won't call greatest
comeback ever not possible yet but but
if she goes down in this one we're
getting we're getting close to that line
where unfortunately only
20 minutes left in the match right you
don't think she can win like nine games
and around yeah just because of the
amount of time that's the thing about
chess daddy you never know remember
Fabiano Carolina of course winning seven
games in a row and the sink you know
thought that was right in speaking of
our of our cap score that's the next one
that's coming out as we've done a lot of
research of the single greatest
performances of all time and we reviewed
about fifteen of them right you've got
like Fisher's run through the candidates
and the Soviet Union you've got car
Juana's dominant Sinquefield Cup we've
pulled some other like runs of like Kaba
Blancas greatest series of games so
that's gonna be a cool one coming out
where we've tried to say hey here's the
greatest chess ones of all time and
here's who played the most accurate
brand of chess according to how
modern-day engines would look at it I
have a feeling it's gonna be that
performance by follow me all right I
won't tell you but I won't spoil it but
I will say that there is another
modern-day performance that is that is
right up there as well that's a really
fun so so 96-well this position looks
gorgeous for Fabiano Carolina yep when
he's down a piece though so we'll see if
he can or if you fun can wiggle her way
out of this the only problem is it's
hard to be down a piece I mean it's hard
to be under the attack but it's even
harder to be under the attack when you
only have 13 seconds and that Queen is
that Queen is being chased everywhere
yeah it's moved like six times in a row
as a net and the knight 98 is a possible
move as well now the bishop has come to
e7 but things like Knight f4 now trying
to take advantage instead nice thing is
that she can always hold on if we ever
get to play f5 she can always play 95 so
ya know kind of going towards the Queen
side instead but Noah
now she's managing a little bit of a
blockade here on the light squares and
and that's right what's gonna make it
yeah oh but this pawn on e5 now hands
and rook to e3 is a fret
you can tell she missed that one rookie
seven beautiful very nice movie six well
that was a tough one I think she saw
this idea of Queen h5 and thought she
could maybe simplify it out with Queen
h8 but just missed the rookie 7-pin so
all right well you fawns got to get on
the board here she's not gonna get she's
not gonna get blinked at bullit I know
she's gonna get some victories so uh
we'll see how she does she's she's
sticking with this sort of interesting
Kings Indiana stuff and this is this is
entering the territory Fabiana really
putting on a high level chess show today
and you fawn playing super well so I
don't even think it's it's because of
you know his opponent I think that he's
just playing super great he's actually
won eight and a half of the last nine
games Jen this is about as good of a run
as we've seen yeah I mean she struggled
with a little more but I think that her
performance in the Blitz and the
3-minute games it was mostly because of
Fabiano's um excellent play yep agreed
agreed
and this is a weird one nail kind of a
fun one I think she can take on no she
can't take on e4 d4 would have been a
bigger problem but we'll see what kind
of counter play she gets here the
biggest worry you have his moves like
Bishop d4 and there he goes he plays it
because the dark squares are dark
squares are an issue here yeah I mean
that Queen coming to defy is gonna force
night d1 but now huh well she might just
she might just have made problems I was
gonna say maybe he can play Queen takes
g3 d takes c6 and Bishop h3 here
threatening mate because the knight is
pinned to the king I think yeah he's
thinking about that right now you can
tell he's a queen g3 in d c6 you're
saying bishop h3 and we don't have time
for Queen d4 yeah he's he's going for
that although maybe we do have time for
Queen D yeah that's the problem so
instead of that maybe we start with her
case to Bishop e5 is a move here Jen cuz
it's friends rook H one mate yep but he
found it I was gonna say that's a
problem
rook me
a nice lawn Rick h1 king h1 he needs to
mate yeah right as right as he plays it
we realize I don't know that it's
stoppable I don't know that she can okay
she finds no she doesn't find it because
we're cage one is still problems s there
and Fabiano me show right now
you know I don't think she got rattled
when she was losing so many games in the
Blitz but now in the bullet portion it's
there's not enough time to recover and
it does seem like it's affecting her I
agree I agree it seems like she's a
little bit a little bit rattled right
now and as we check on the total time
remaining we have only 13 minutes left
in the match so unfortunately pretty
clear at this point who's moving on but
check out our bracket is our bracket is
not quite updated yet but pretty clear
who's gonna be moving on here we will
have an updated bracket soon and
interesting stuff though I think it'll
be fun to see how she felt about the
match obviously she played really really
well and then maybe psychologically got
a little bit down on herself as she lost
a couple bullet games yeah I think the
bullet is definitely am definitely a
huge issue here as a Bobby is just
proving so supreme in this particular
format but Queen before here okay let's
see if she can get on the board here on
the bullet and snag it a game from him
because I'm I feel like I'm liking black
here we haven't given up any material on
our developments quite good
b7 is hanging at the moment but it looks
like that looks kind of greedy doesn't
have yep
rook c8 we're thinking about playing
Burke takes c3
so she's played with c7 also kicking the
b7 pawn and she's got almost a 20-second
time advantage I do think this is gonna
be the game where she gets on the board
and the bullet I think not to jinx her
anything I've been known to do that we
both have I was wondering why she didn't
play Bishop c4 there she must have seen
something that I didn't see I thought
Bishop c4 might have might have
prevented white from from getting that
King out of the center but no but now
she looks like c4 is going down I mean
c3 rather yeah it's gonna be gonna be
kind of a Peter out here she wins the a3
pawn and we'd like to think has a small
advantage here but maybe not if black
takes I thought white would take b7
there but the everything what's going on
here be one yeah okay yeah sorry I was
just blanking there for a second so now
there's Brooke b2 but with these super
active rocks yeah this looks very
promising so that of course Bobby I know
I'm realizes immediately you can't go
super passive here
yep trying to get out he's gonna bring
the bring the rooks to the seventh rank
and her time advantage has disappeared
that's not good because that was really
what I was banking on here that with the
superior position and the clock she
would be able to win this one but now
she's actually behind one time yeah she
still got a decent chances here she she
can run the a pawn I thought maybe she
would try to swing the rooks to the
e-file and maybe work together there but
these pieces are flying so fast yeah
it's hard to keep track of exactly what
the most accurate moves might have been
there she plays a3 she's still playing
for a win okay no now I think we just
got a draw and and that's okay a draw is
a draw there you know redraws in this
match so we don't break the Carlsen
Petrosian record today and Fabiano
biting into a piece of watermelon got a
full
BL smorgasbord of snacks there I love it
watermelon I could use some water people
then that sounds delicious watermelon
everything sounds delicious right now
right I think a nap sounds delicious to
me right now I cannot wait to go home
and take a nap sounds like somebody with
three kids yeah four kids I work for and
writing on writing on a lot of
commentary this week so pretty excited
this is the end of the week and then we
got we got mvl vs. Jeffrey Zhang next
week
August 30th an amazing match and
seriously though it actually doesn't
show you seem you still seem very
energetic about about this I mean after
all anything could still happen in this
match Danny yep well well we anything
could still happen in the sense that any
chess moves could still happen
yes but map it mathematically
unfortunately it would take it would
take a miracle against the the running
clock
exactly just not enough games left for
who you find to come back and we've kind
of like unofficially thought that this
was over for quite a while but earlier
in the magic really seemed like it could
have gone either way no I mean you and
she won that last five-minute game and
we moved to a four-four tie right after
the after the mouse lip in the chess960
game I was I was ready on the edge of my
seat and I I think you know I think she
still played well in the three-minute
but I think if anything it just showed
that Fabiana really you know really
zoned in and you know just played played
higher higher quality chefs and now
ninety four is coming yeah I was gonna
say she may win this one though this
this is one where she is now up on time
and I think really has an advantage you
just like those you like the two bishops
especially that Bishop stingy to which
is unopposed to watch out for cranking
open the diagonal yes she gobbles the b5
pawn which makes sense and she's still
much better here grab the C file again
probably Brooke c1 yeah and maybe you
can play f4 now that's what I do just
started packing
she starts she plays Knight f3 and she's
just playing quick moves this is bullet
chess after all this is nice maneuver
though now she comes back and if the
knight comes to e5 f4 is even stronger
Knight coming to c6 e 5 even waiting for
that move to come in and there it is
Ian kettle Knight looks whoa phone b7
yeah that is not a happy night a good
pin for white here and this is where you
fall gets the victory Knight takes c6
Queen g4 and Bishop before coming and
she's just gonna take on at five and
then and then mate black in the mill the
board and yifan winds at bullet and I
told you anything can still happen
that's right it was a nice a nice win
the score moves to 16 and a half to
to seven-and-a-half overall which is
okay and now we've gotta know this
position where it looks like again we're
seeing one of these ninja-like positions
with a English opening move order where
five is that the two bishops and he's
gonna try to try to open up the position
for them 96 kind of anticipating all of
our evil diabolical intentions with that
for yeah this position is 90 and knights
coming to f5 I've got to love that night
on i-5 that's not there yet but will be
soon and there it is Queen f6 you know
she wants to make sure to to prove some
resistance against ideas like queen g4
and h4 without gaining on g7 so that's
the reason why that Queen sitting there
enough sex
of course she'd love to trade off that
beautiful night on f5 oh yes the night
on d7 we just ripped off a pawn for free
yeah as well as exposing your king yeah
well even before this one is over the
score right now 16 and a half 17 and a
half and and he's eating watermelon and
eat and Fabiano Caruana enjoying some
watermelon and we we know who's moving
on at this point we don't know what that
final score will be but it is currently
going to be it's gonna be Fabiano
Caruana for Sakura Nakamura which will
be fun
hey Carl probably big favorite there
with the bullet and Hikaru's online
prowess but it should still be
interesting to see those American rivals
go at it looking forward more to Fabiano
Caruana Hikaru Nakamura or Magnus
Carlsen Wesley so assuming Magnus is
able to get by the 16 Sika deer kusenov
oh which one am i looking more forward
yeah
gosh tough one but I'll have to go with
the world champion verse Wesley so just
any time you see the world champion
against one of our American stars it
makes me think about what if right I'm
playing in the World Championships in
Ohio I love the matchup classic matchup
between Bobby and naka but we do get to
see that matchup quite often right but
it's a great one so much history there
Danny
yep and this this game what's going on
here has o got any extra chances here is
the clock ticks down though it looks
like she's just ticking away
yeah and Fabiano takes the extra piece
right there which kind of a sign that ya
the position has run out and already
living off the increment with one second
left she decides to call it a day so
we're back to a 10 game lead for Fabiano
three and a half minutes left in the
match not not too much longer before we
get to catch up with these players which
is always a fun time and so don't go
anywhere everybody we will have a chat
with the players as soon as the match is
over and of course even with only three
minutes left of the bullet there is one
more chess960 game left oh I've got a
love I hope 960 bullet there's only one
brand of Ches crazier than 960 bullet
when you've never seen the position
before and you know what that is Jen
that's our giant chess giant chess is
probably the only brand of chess crazier
than 960 bullet and you know you gotta
love that workout that's right the
that's what we need next-gen chess960
giant chess then we're talking no that
would be that's that's a little
unnecessary
oh no she's winning a piece no she's not
no clearly she doesn't yeah there's
makings d4 and then after Caixin f6
Bishop takes f6 protects the naive yep
nice a bear by Fabi but she's still uh
she's still doing okay here I think if
she just moves the knight she's got an
edge with the dominant Queen in the
center
no she decides to take is she gonna take
on f6 and ninety five come on take
yes we're gonna have an awesome queen
sack and fell he shakes his head Jenny
this is how we're gonna end the match
right here that is some sassy chest
right there Queen takes f6 so I'm for
that you know we kept referencing this
uh this beautiful report by my client
and she has rookie seven here if she
doesn't want to take the Queen back with
me seven come on seven oh seven this
works to kind of wow increasing the
pressure and out the problem for Bobby
is that Bishop f6 was a real threat yeah
and after rook t6 what's at the end
she's up one pawn but okay so where does
a decent job of preventing my majority
from expanding so at least a sack that
at least a sack that worked in the sense
that certainly white is better here but
I wonder if that move rookie seven I got
to go over to our to our analysis board
I can't I can't let that one go sorry I
just I got to see it we got to ask us
about it we got to ask her about this
later but unfortunately like she's what
she's lost from playing that a brilliant
bullet sacrifice was that she is a
little bit low on time so she didn't
have time to come up with your idea it
works I don't know if it worked either I
think it might he's I tend to go too far
with things but I don't know I have a
feeling it worked well we'll get we'll
get some confirmation from my engine
partner look that up Pete you got to
look it up rookie 7 anyway but one way
or the other your your description was
app Fafi in brilliant let's do it let's
say let's see if she can win that pawn
and get her second bullet game here this
was certainly a fun one either way
because now she's putting on some decent
technique King D 2 gobbled the B for
pawn and and she is in business this is
probably going to be the last official
game up look at that a very nice rook
charade by Fabiano he's probably gonna
hold now yeah in fact the world was
going on here is he just better all of a
sudden I would be insane no no no way
he's just better now
but it is interesting yeah because and
they're just they're just drawn by
repetition but what a way to finish the
bullet portion with such a nice
sacrifice so even though it's just a 1
minute game we can go and look at that
position later and see like was that
good that's what you gotta love about
groups what just happened what you phone
accidentally started a game against
somebody who she shouldn't be playing oh
no oh no uh-uh and she notices it
Pete was supposed to start the game oh
it's a 3-minute game I said so who is a
local you oh jeez okay there we go I
think I seen the emoji keys in the UH in
the chat actually but um it looks like
maybe what you find is trying to figure
out what to do now maybe she will abort
the mass or something this game and oh
and here we go yeah she's been aborted
and we've got our chess960 bullet last
game of the match win lose or draw this
has been a blast and somebody snuck in
there shame on that person who was just
waiting it it's probably what happens to
these players sometimes during their
playing is they're kind of getting
spammed with challenges we often advise
them to kind of turn off all challenges
from our members who refuse to
acknowledge that this person is playing
a speech chess match and try to try to
challenge them every game in between
games so here we go we've got this thing
head on Queen which I know you love oh
my gosh I was in pain last time and it
ended up not working out well but this
is a very dangerous route 66 almost came
there then 95 here Bishop c5 just scored
the rocks yeah so it's less than ideal
yeah that it's tough sometimes in 1960
when you're black and your positions
worse it's it's not easy no it really is
and we do try to do our best to try to
choose positions that are as close to
the you know evaluation of classical
chess in terms of who's better but
times it's just not true I mean you get
physicians that are or even if they
start out that way like literally one
wrong move and suddenly white is just
much better in chess960 right it happens
very quickly so it's sometimes really
tough but does black have some
compensation here because that that ePHI
pond is going to go mmm
Queen c5 looks like a good be a good one
and now the bishop one ina each one is
also in the game that's the problem
and none of flat and the queen is on b2
but none of flax other pieces are in the
game and that's a problem like it should
be three trucks just Keaney one yeah
white king is greening out and it's only
a matter of time before this Bishop on
c6 moves and unleashes a nasty nasty
discovered attack against here it comes
Bishop e7 Chuck and then Queen takes e7
maybe no apparently not they can't
always be as good as you Danny yeah
right he does fight it next but I took
an extra move that big of my don't know
I don't I don't think he's I'm not even
sure him works okay it does work I guess
but yeah but but yeah I took him one
extra move but not not much extra he
does find it and with that we move on to
the interview portion of the of the show
today and just awesome chess here I'm
gonna go ahead and invite both of our
players back if they are here Fabiano
and you fawn can you hear us yes
Fabiana you there fantastic match guys I
think javi Anna was with us as well
congratulations on your victory you find
you you played phenomenal chess the
match was the match was super close
there it was tied 4-4 heading into the
three-minute portion and it seemed that
after a few games got away from you
toward the end of the three-minute that
maybe maybe you got a little rattled do
you feel like you maybe got a little
frustrated toward the end or just just
how the
when no not really I got I felt like I
got some chances okay but sit down one
time wrong I mean run south somehow
there's like a huge brown those occurred
the like a many games yeah did you have
you have you played a lot of bullet
chests online I wonder I'm Fabiano and
and you fought how much how much bullet
do you play regularly online uh I used
to play a lot more in the past I used to
play a lot of one minute but I actually
I haven't played very often with the one
second agreement which changes us a lot
because you actually have to play real
chess well in one minute and bullet you
could just like oh like it's like your
opponent's rose you can't do here so I
mean I still feel a little bit rusty in
this one minute it goes by so fast did
you feel extra prepared though because
of the same Lois racket and blitz and
all those late night blitz sessions um
no I I didn't feel very well prepared
it's it's still very different playing
online and playing over the board very
different type of words which one do you
think you specialize in more oh I
probably don't specialize in either
I feel more comfortable over the more at
least around that like somewhere in the
around like the five-minute to second
for a five-minute portion
I just thought stop seeing anything I
just couldn't couldn't even see where
the pieces were anymore or a night I
mean rook rook d7 was probably the
lowest point um Bobby will you run will
you raise your laptop a little bit so we
can see more of your face you do have a
great neck by the way I have to tell you
but can you great can you raise your
could you raise your your laptop screen
a little more so we can see your face
directly just push your there we go
right there can you say there yeah okay
sorry just fans want to see your face
that's all we are
it's okay you're doing fine you find
overall the match was super close and it
seemed that you you know the match a lot
of the games could have gone either way
in the
critical moments maybe you were down a
little bit more on time but what was
your assessment in terms of where where
maybe some of the games got away from
you and and as far as how you look back
at things yeah I mean definitely mirror
chances let's say start from this three
plus two bullets or somehow I I mean I
saw the way this the first of all to row
Calkins which is quite a bit upset and
got a little family America and okay the
bullet games it was just like I mean
just like this and I'm sure that's both
I miss a lot of things right we know
it's a bullet game but we loved your
final bullet game with the Queen
sacrifice yeah that was pretty awesome
because I could this some something
mistakes thought okay I decide to just
try something more interesting and
improperly it's actually words I mean
probably they were otherwise than what I
did I did look it did work did you
consider rookie seven instead of um
instead of playing rook to d1 blocking
information he shot me six okay and then
after Bishop takes f6 anyway yes I
should play ap seven well I don't know
we were just night six of six I was very
worried about rookie seven but I thought
I can take it and play Bishop e6
and although probably this pin is just
you know it's gonna kill me G for
something I I have to review something I
didn't really see a great move was
really a remarkable moment one minute
just for us to be treated to such an
exciting sacrifice so that was a good
way to end the match yeah it was it was
fun regardless of the I'm bringing it up
right now
rookie seven just because it was super
fun similar to the greatness Medina of
sacrifice in the Sicilian there but
rookie seven maybe there there was also
this Queen sac earlier in the in the
match when you fawn found this really
nice combination with ninety three to
win a pawn and then you decided to
sacrifice the Queen on d1 did you miss
93 it seemed you did and then kind of
came up with this idea yeah I realized
that my t3 is it's pretty bad and while
I was thinking I was considering my
options I can either play a pawn down or
sack my queen I thought I thought sake
my queen might be a better option what
it's really really bad anyway right
well I don't I know you're both you're
both pretty tired after a long match and
although your day is just getting
started there in Beijing you fun.i yes
so you you were very tired in the
beginning of the match and maybe now of
getting ready for the day but I want to
thank you both obviously for just an
awesome match tons of fans tuning in we
were we were greatly entertained and
educated you guys did teach us a lot
with the Blitz and um Fabiano you're
moving on to face a Cara Nakamura in the
next round how do you think you stack up
in this format obviously you've had
you've had lots of games against Hikaru
before and and you've even you know when
when many people thought he was the
favorite and that st. Louis showdown you
took him down and wrap it in blitz how
do you think you stack up with a caro in
the online format i think that the main
difficulty for me will be a 2-1 minute
portion because this is one in which
he's probably had head and shoulders
above every other player in the world or
or at least definitely one of the very
best at one minute chefs
the rest I peel I have my chances that
one I'll have to are pretty seriously
poor to try to hold my own in one minute
got it well you fought this was a lot of
fun did you have fun yeah enjoy it and
actually this is my first really Kerdi
go experience to play online which I
didn't really try a lot before right
then was quite exciting well we can't
wait to have you do it again so this is
something that the fans really liked and
it was great to see you guys up close
and playing all these games very closely
contested games Jan any other questions
or comments for our awesome players here
before we let them go how's that
watermelon funny I have to get I had
some I needed some food because I was
feeling so dizzy at some point during
the match I mean seriously you played so
many amazing instructive games despite
the fact that they were just blitz games
didn't do any of them like um strike you
because I know it's probably all
blurring together
um probably at the start of the match so
my some of my games work with some of
the games in the French I I liked but I
felt like at the start of it was going
very well and then and then my level
just dropped so massively from like
games one and two to two the rest of the
five-minute portion but there were some
decent games in there I think yeah we
definitely agree just very few blunders
actually so really it was a it was a joy
to UM and so many dynamic games with
like the French's and the Royal Oh PES
that kind of burst open just towards the
end of the time control I'm just as you
guys had 30 seconds left so it was
really a so fabulous for us thank you
both so much
yeah and I know it's easy to say that
now but having to do a lot of these
matches I can say it was really
impressive that we've really had pretty
much no blitz blunders as we call them
probably until your mouth slip in the
chess960 Fabiano and then when you fawn
played the the rook a six check and and
lost the rook to the bishop I think
those are the only two just like massive
blunders which is really impressive I I
didn't I which I didn't make a Muslim
when you played rook take C - that
wasn't a mouse slip you just missed the
night oh wait was I was rude yeah those
were two so it's Ricky - yeah no I this
was um I was Black Knight yeah yeah now
it's all budding together but that was a
legitimate blunder I thought it was a
pre pawn yeah Jen and I were like well
he must have been intending rookie 3
because there's no way he would have
played rook take C - that's what we
thought
no I start I wants to play 93 it was I
was planning to play a 93 and then and
then for some reason I thought it was a
free pawn and then I took it I realized
that and I even pre moved Queen takes
that's why it was a pre move okay then
that makes a little more sense okay so a
few blunders in the match but still less
than expected pretty high-quality we all
enjoyed it so much thank you both
you fawn we can't wait to have you do
this again next year speed chess
championship Fabiano good luck in the
next round against the core Nakamura
thank you lecie of course and good luck
to both you into policing
that's right okay thank you thank you
both have a great day you fawn and have
a good night Fabiano yes good morning
and good night okay bye-bye
well Jen it was a lot of fun and awesome
chess there and I think it was a lot
closer than than we thought it might be
and and obviously it got away there from
Yifan toward the end but still a lot of
fun we have Fabiana moving on maybe you
and I will have the call in that one
Fabiano car we haven't set the schedule
yet for hosts and broadcast in round two
but we are greatly looking forward to it
and thanks for thanks for flying along
with me today I had a great time thanks
to everybody tuning in for speed chess
and yeah I'd love to be a part of future
speech just matches it's it's so much
fun so dynamic so many attacking games
and interesting combination so good
night everybody and thanks for having me
on Danny thank you for being here bye
everybody
[Music]
checker
chess is a game of unlimited beauty but
it's not just checks than attacks you
have to be creative
let's convert King g5 king c2 king of
six can be speak English 17 C 14 to 16
before King second-guessing boom what
most yes Queen takes the knight f5 and
it's a double attack so let's go back
and see what's the next logical Lois
cure and attraction and its mate
what an amazing mate
I've been thinking about few ideas that
I never used what I want to show that's
one of my favorite outbreaks it's not
about winning or losing
but of course at the end of the day it's
about winning I'm Gary Kasparov and this
is my master